e
it is now 10 o'clock we will get started
and welcome the conservation land
stewardship program so welcome and which
we are on page
105 and this appears to have two
employees I guess you're one of
them oh okay one's vacant
is yeah thank you perfect testing
okay yeah um so my name is Charlotte
Harding I previously worked with uh
Steve Walker who is the director of the
conservation land stewardship
program uh and my supervisor Steve has
since retired so I'm here um the
overarching purpose of the conservation
land stewardship program is to protect
the state's investments in interests on
conservation lands so we help monitor
Steward and provide oversight for
conservation easements which the state
and um I am familiar with our budget I
was involved with the FY uh 2627 budget
development and if you have any
questions that I don't know the answer
to um I am happy to follow up uh with
with answers to those all right thank
you on the page
106 um uh transfers from other agencies
and agents talk about the source of
funds right so yes um so we currently
have two sources of funding one of those
sources is from an endowment that is
held at the State Treasury and
administered by the Council on resources
and
development the other source of funding
which would be the transfer from other
agencies is um those are funds provided
by the fish and game department for
monitoring of
conservation
easements uh that are not held in that
treasury so these endowment funds that's
uh some dedicated fund that um we could
look up in RSA 612 is that uh yes so I
believe RSA 162
C8 um was uh what established the the
endowment at treasury we call it the
land conservation endowment but that's
okay I think it just says the endowment
in that
RSA does it get new money from
anything it does uh
so outside of that contract that's
listed as the 001 transferred from other
agencies uh fishing game when they uh
develop new conservation easement
properties they
um work with us and partner agencies to
actually contribute a to add a
contribution to the land conservation
endowment um and that is for the
Perpetual uh monitoring and stewardship
of that
property okay representative evil um
thank you very much for being here and
for what you do if I understand what the
purpose of this program is it's to
protect the state's interest in lands
that we have conservation easements
correct on so um just give us an example
of a couple of important pieces of
property uh that you would be involved
in because it seems to me that you have
a important role to fill for our state
yeah um so our program was uh when it
was originally created it was known as
the land conservation investment program
which was a uh a land acquisition
program that ran in the late 80s to
early 90s and the state acquired over
100,000 acres of conservation land
through that program and about half of
those properties were acquired by state
departments in fee meaning that uh
fishing game or Department of Natural
and cultural resources uh outright own
those properties and manage them
internally um and then the other half of
those properties were acquired as
conservation easements owned by private
land owners some are nonprofits uh some
are just private
citizens um some of the larger pieces of
properties that we are involved with
would include the musoma headwaters area
up in uh
Canan I'm trying to think of oh uh there
is a very large uh elip property in
gilmington that was preserved by uh the
the Boy Scouts organization and it's now
known as the the Hidden Valley Boy Scout
camp um and that backs up to other lcip
properties as well so there are
groupings of properties to create large
tracks of uh forested
lands I am trying to think of some other
that you might recognize the name of
well so lcip was the was the uh
organization that preceded the creation
of lchip right Andre so it was financed
by the state as I recall and so the
state was actually buying properties
pursuant to this lcip program that was
replaced is Nash stream or any of those
large properties up there part of what
was acquired through
lcip yes so Nash stream was acquired
through the lcip in fee uh so we don't
have involvement with that particular
property because it is managed by uh the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources okay but yeah that was a I
believe the largest property acquired
through the lcip one that I remembered
okay thank you so I don't see any money
in here for like tree trimming or
anything so what what do you do with
these properties yeah so um what we do
as far as stewardship it's it's really
it's hands off so as opposed to doing
Trail work and maintaining boundaries
what we do to protect the state's
interest is first and foremost maintain
relationships with the land owners and
we communicate with them annually to go
over changes to those properties in past
years and plans for changes in the
coming years we uh Monitor and inspect
the boundaries of these properties to
check for encroachments
uh from from a Butters we monitor the
properties to ensure that they're being
used um according to the purposes of the
conservation easement Deeds which we
consider to be the The Authority for
proper use of those properties uh so we
can look for
incompatible uh public uses many of the
properties do not allow let's say
motorized wheeled vehicles or um or
General recreation activities that
wouldn't be considered to be transitory
and
passive uh almost all of the properties
are open to public access uh including
for hunting and fishing hiking basically
low impact uses so we monitor the
properties uh every year for
incompatible uses that are not allowed
by those conservation easement
Deeds so it's all about easements as
opposed to property the state owns is
that correct correct okay thank you are
any other questions representative
evil I apologize it's not exactly a
question but um I've been involved in
some land trust type organizations and
when what can happen is people can start
building on these preserved lands and
and you know like breaking through the
the um deed requirements and and um and
just like misusing the land there can be
dumping on on lands like this of
hazardous waste and so part of
stewardship once you get a conservation
easement or the state owns something in
fee which she's involved in you just
have to make sure that um it's being
used properly that's basically that's
correct so it's just a really important
role they
fill just a moment so Jack could you get
us the page from the dedicated funds
reports for this
endowment land endowment um dedicated
fund all right thank you represent
W was going to be my question do you
have a dedicated fund you obviously do
yes do you remember the
title the title of the dedicated fund I
I I believe the treasury has the title
as the land conservation
endowment so basically the operation in
your office is is going out and checking
on all these properties I see you've
gone up in your your your uh
instate travels going way
up yes and the primary reason for that
is because our we were using a state
issued vehicle that we had
actually we didn't acquire it ourselves
it was a bit of a hand-me-down from the
office that we were previously embedded
within we were a part of the office of
strategic
initiatives um so we had been using that
vehicle over the past several years
since that office disbanded uh the
vehicle is no longer
functional um we I believe had listed a
new vehicle as one of our prioritized
needs uh for the new banum but we have
few maybe I don't know how to put it but
basically um cord who timately holds the
Authority for uh all lcip lands and
administers uh funds from our endowment
has identified some issues as far as um
our our ability to procure a new vehicle
um so we raised our funds for instate
travel so that we can use our our
personal vehicles to go ahead and
monitor those properties do we need the
second person in this office and if if
we get a second person are they going to
do something different than what you're
doing now or more of the same that's a
good question
um I would say that the office
runs more efficiently with two
people um as far as whether it's a need
I'll I'll say that I have been covering
my role as as well as the directors for
the past 2 months since he retired so it
is possible to run as a single full-time
Staff
ideal thank you representative Camal
thank you Mr chair so did do you and the
former director actually go into the
field to do all the inspections
yourselves yes we do we also we do have
a a seasonal position um
see trying to find where that would be
class 050 yes so class 050 is um to fund
our our seasonal position and we
actually just onboarded our seasonal and
the seasonal uh focuses heavily on
monitoring as well so um but yes the the
two full-time positions also monitor I
would say that traditionally the
director's role spends a lot more time
in the office uh taking care of the
administrative side of things while uh
the the
position supervised by the director
focuses more heavily on the field okay
and uh what is your enforcement arm is
it fishing game who enforces when you do
find violations yeah thank you um so so
CLS uh ourselves we do not have
enforcement Authority so we do refer
enforcement issues over to the grantee
agencies who hold these conservation
easements uh when an easement when an
issue is found with an lcip easement
those grantee agencies have the option
to forward that enforcement authority
over to the Council on resources and
development if that grantee agency feels
that they are um not comfortable
addressing the
issue
yeah thank you Jack was the um on class
17 this extra 11,000 in fiscal year 25
retirement okay do you know I believe it
is yeah because I think there's some
kind of payment you get right on
retirement right right yeah okay very
good all right other questions no no I I
was just going to say so basically
you're you're monitoring the State
Properties identifying if there are
issues and then sending those issues to
the like fish and game or whomever to do
the enforcement um right but some of
that of course can be working with the
land owners to try to get the infraction
worked out I mean some of these things
can be really a lot of work and some not
so much so yes it could be something as
small as you know in a butter throwing a
Christmas tree over a boundary and
something as large as a property
being subdivided uh when the easement
says no subdivision is allowed or uh a
structure is built without uh grantee
permissions and its purpose is not um
compatible with the purposes of the
easement so yeah we do uh we do our best
to work from the landowner level up so
when we do find issues uh smaller issues
we tend to work with land owners in
abutters to go ahead and correct those
to
um to mostly to save on on staff time
and uh because we know that the granty
agencies themselves they don't
manage these properties um
and we've experienced when we have
forwarded some issues over to granty
agencies they often uh don't have the
bandwidth to to deal with it in the
short term so so I I think the upshot is
in addition to doing the monitoring you
do work with land owners to work out
issues at sort of a lower more user
friendly yes level yeah and the best way
to avoid issues is to maintain uh a
relationship let me ask this so I'm we
now have your dedicated fund report here
do you have a copy yeah uh no I do not
put on this side there you go so
um where it says other sources of funds
so when someone puts land into
conservation gives you a conservation
easement that somehow generates a fee
that goes into this fund is that right
or a payment of some kind yeah so when
fish and game uh gets a new conservation
easement they're typically work working
with a partner organization and the
funds that get um contributed to the
endowment come directly from those
partner
organizations and the fee that is
contributed is based on a stewardship
calculator which is a a matrix we use to
determine
um what what the appropriate
contribution would be that's based on a
10 years of stewardship and we've also
been advised by the treasury that uh we
should count on withdrawing no more than
4 and a half% of um the investment
income from the endowment per
year so um I understand okay do you know
what happened in 2022 there was a large
a million dollars taken away from this
fund
in
2022 I am not sure off the top of my
head what that what caused that thank
you yeah the reduction in funds all
right um well I think that's one more
question no I wondered if I could make a
motion no I I'm I'm not quite ready to
take a motion so we'll we'll talk about
this okay so the only other thing I
wanted to say I is is it a correct
statement to say that um when proper
in recognition of the amount of work
that it takes to ensure that easements
are respected by land
owners is it a correct statement to say
that there's been a lot more emphasis on
stewardship within the land protection
Community now recognizing there's an
ongoing responsibility and that it costs
money yes yeah in the in the
conservation Community um there is more
emphasis being placed on stewardship
because you know it's it's always
exciting to protect a new piece of land
but that's really when the work begins
and yeah needing to protect it
representative camell thank you Mr chair
uh the open position for the director I
know that there's a hiring freeze right
now but were they actively looking for
candidates and did you have any
candidates lined up before the
freeze um so I was I was informed at the
end of the day yesterday by HR that I
would be getting a a 90 a temporary
promotion into the director's
position um so I don't think that there
were any candidates lined up beforehand
although I did let HR know that I was
interested in the in the director's
position so
yep thank you very much I mean one thing
we could do with these is leave her plus
more temps right more summer jobs right
yeah yep
okay all right well we'll talk about
that later all right thank you very much
for coming it looks like we got a a 9
minute recess or
you
e
this has five okay it it is now 10:30
and we will welcome
um good morning Mr chair Paul Breen
peace Development Authority executive
director and I'm accompanied by Susie
director I'd be happy to give a quick
overview of I know uh we're specifically
talking about the operating budget for
division of ports and harbors yes um
statute legislative statute 12g
basically enabled the peace Development
Authority in the early 90s uh about a
decade after that uh the division of
ports and harbors was transferred to the
peace Development Authority for
administrative oversight
uh specifically the peace Development
Authority we provide Finance legal uh
environmental and Engineering um support
to the to the division of ports and
harbors um division of ports and harbors
the primary focus is maritime uh
Maritime Economic Development on our
waterways um main facility is 55 Market
Street deep water birth New Hampshire's
only deep water birth and then we have
um additional harbors and Hampton campon
New Hampshire and Ry New Hampshire uh
commercial recreational uh business
businesses and then we're also
responsible for the Portsmouth fish Pier
which is a commercial fishing venue that
supports um both drag netting and
lobster fishing uh out of out of the out
of Portsmouth New Hampshire and then
finally responsible for the navigational
Waters the pascar uh in Great Bay in off
of Newton and durm um happy to what
about the airport and related properties
yeah so specifically peace Development
Authority the enabling statute was to
was to be the airport sponsor for
Portsmith International Airport after um
the air force closed P Air Force Base
under the Brack closure in
1991 um specifically uh there was a a
land public transfer that allowed the
Department of Defense to maintain the
New Hampshire Air National Guard so
approximately 2400 Acres um were
transferred to the state of New
Hampshire um the thought process was was
to create a sustainable airport to
support the the Air National Guard uh
they currently still have a incredible
presence with their KC 46 modern
refueling Fleet um and in order to
sustain those financial obligations of
maintaining that large Airfield facility
the state was allowed to develop the
property um which is now the peas trade
Port industrial Commerce Park um
essentially it's a closed fiscal system
that any Revenue we generate from the
non- aono activity um and the
aeronautical activity that goes on there
goes into essentially an Enterprise fund
that allows us to maintain and operate
the Airfield that supports the
department of defenses the New Hampshire
International guards U Mission so none
of that shows up here it's it's only
Port related things that's correct we we
keep two sets of books um and that
really is a you know an FAA requirement
in our Federal grant assurance and and
that stems back to the original land
public transfer um so we keep two sets
of books one for the division of ports
and harbors and one's for one for PE
Development Authority um and also it
should be known that the division and
ports and harbors is also
self-sustaining our operating budget
does not impact the state's general fund
um we do from time to time
um uh use use resources of the states
but they're they're paid back through
through the work that that that uh your
your Finance team does um in Suzie is
there a dedicated fund for the airport
there is a dedicated fund um essentially
all of the funds um that are involved
with the exception of division Imports
and revenue is all airport
funds
okay so Melissa we can look at that okay
all right so go ahead um let's talk
about you have two two sections here one
with two people and one with
three yes so basically the only uh line
items really in in our budget are wages
and benefits and some smaller
administrative costs for insurance uh uh
watercraft policy and so um as these
costs are incurred um we reimburse the
state quarterly and we do an annual
reconciliation um to make sure that that
uh you know everything's been reimbursed
and um so as Paul mentioned uh the
expens expenditures um for the um
division of ports and harbors don't have
any impact on the state's general fund
everything is
reimbursed and so we have uh you know
five positions and like I said just
benefits and some smaller administrative
costs so it's reimbursed because you
charge fees to people who bring in ships
is yeah the revenue is uh we're
generating the revenue from uh war and
dockage fees parking fees registration
fees moing fees um and that's what's
used to cover our operating expenses not
only the ones uh that are reflected here
but also the operating expenses that are
not um that are not at I guess what
you'd call the state level all right
let's start on page
518 so there's a big jump in overtime
from uh fiscal year 24 to 25 and Beyond
would you be better off with a temp
instead of all that overtime pardon me
yeah so this budget is put together by
the department of administrative
services and so I don't know if they're
just allowing for some wiggle room but
um you know I think that if you're
looking to decrease some of the
expenditures this would be a line item
that we could um so you don't think
you're really using this amount of
overtime no well not I would just say
the nature of the business is at the
mercy of uh Commerce
specifically um the the bulk of the
overtime is related to our security plan
at the deep water Port um and that is
reluctant on relies on the activity of
the vessels that are coming in for
instance um most of you probably dealing
with um salt roadway salt shortages at
your at your hometowns um so we've seen
an uptick in those salt Ships coming
into the port uh that will create more
overtime to meet our security
requirements for those International
vessels um so it's somewhat uh fluid and
we so you're saying the vessel could
come in Sunday night or something and
then there' be over corre so we may have
a if there's no snow and inclement
weather next year we may not have as as
many vessels come in so we don't want to
commit to a a permanent or uh temp
employee at that level but uh obviously
our unit managers monitor this and if we
need it we'll certainly um you know put
put additional labor in okay and last
year's expenditures too there was not a
lot of activity um coming through the
port we were doing a construction
project and so we had fewer salt Ships
coming in so although it is a lower
number you know for the next two fiscal
years you know I can see a decrease but
I don't think that it's going to be as
low as it was in fiscal year 24 okay um
and then the workers comp line is is a
huge jump what's going on with that
one workers
comp from
we have seen an an overall uptick in our
workers comp um six that only from 5.8
to
6.6 UMES no that's Property and Casualty
representative McGuire I'm sorry right
under I just wanted to decrease give um
just a couple Melissa a couple of
caveats one for workman's comp that's
just a straight cost from Das that they
get they have no um authority to change
that or adjust that it's a it's a fixed
cost as for their over time in holiday
pay those also are done by Das as an
estimate based on fiscal year 25 so
those will be adjusted but I just wanted
to let you know that's a little bit
different than where other agencies has
pic have picked their numbers Das gives
support they just build it based on what
occurred in 25 and put that number there
I see so you're saying workman's comp in
25 is probably
inaccurate that one's a that one's a
fixed cost
it's a fixed cost that's buil by
Das right but it's going from 8 and one
to 27 and 29 right I mean there's
something something's happening Mo most
thing so Steve is Whispering to me and
I'm just sharing with Das that Statewide
there's an overall increase in workman's
comp so when everybody's line in
workman's comp is going up because the
the overall share is more expensive
point it's tripling
no I mean our workman's comp is is I can
tell you our workman's comp is like the
third lowest in the country right
so there's something weird going on with
this particular line maybe you can find
out separately information all right and
let's go down to um
to P yeah let me ask one more and then
I'll I'll take other question let's go
to page
Das again okay they're hiding all kinds
of expenses on
on yeah but most we're not seeing this
places pass on some more information so
in
24 they did receive a bill but they paid
it outside of New Hampshire first so it
would not show it would be a zero in
here because it did not go through the
budget system they paid it on their own
but typically it would be 25 26 and 27
that's what the costs typically are but
again they would pay them they would pay
it on their their own and it may be a
zero or we we'd be reimbursed for that
amount okay all right well when we see
Das maybe we'll ask them about this kind
of
thing okay all right representative
camell if if you look look down here
there's no come for the salaries so I
to well then it that would be for 24 and
CH yeah we'll find out okay uh
representative cell thank you Mr chair
uh do the revenues ever exceed your
expenses do you do you have good periods
where you can actually make uh more
money than you than you need yeah yes we
do and what that would be done is that
kept in in in our Enterprise fund that
would basically uh Foster Capital
Improvements or Capital replacement okay
so it wouldn't go back to like a general
fund you you keep it and you use it for
improvements correct we utilize it for
Capital Improvements uh potentially
anything from a Federal grant uh local
sponsor sponsorship uh portion of a of a
grant um or we we reinvested into the
facility whether it's fixed assets or um
you know Capital needs okay and the
opposite of that if the revenues are
down and less than uh than what you
anticipated uh how do you make up the
the Delta to to pay your expenses
fortunately I'm I'm proud of the team
that we we manage um fiscally
responsible we haven't been in that
position um we hope not to be in that
position but uh we work very closely on
uh on our operating budget uh on a on a
monthly report to our PDA board um and
then staff works at at it continuously
to make sure that we're not in that
position um and any of those Capital
Improvements would be the first things
that we we would scale back on if we saw
that uh we're we're unable to sustain
our oam and our operating um and
maintenance budget thank you you're
welcome representative Evo yeah um hi
good morning so um is your primary
revenue Source your fees corrected
specifically the warpage and dockage
fees at Market Street Terminal the heavy
the heavy Maritime uh lifts and um do
you have the authority to adjust those
fees yourself we do it is a public
process um we you know we we also have
to gauge the the competitive market
around us um and also uh recognize um
what our limitations are with the
infrastructure specifically there's
three Three brid Bridges um on the
catore that impact what type of vessels
we can can take at at Market Street so
it's a combination of knowing your you
know your infrastructure and what you
can provide our commercial entities um
and also gauging the local market and
what their price points
are some some fees for some agencies are
statutorily set and they haven't been
changed for a long time so I was just
curious what your situation yeah we and
at the smaller uh facilities right now
we're actually um have done quite an
extensive review increasing those that
were stagnant for some time um we think
they're fair and reasonable and the
first thing we do is is look at other
entities at at the state and for
instance uh public parking at our
facilities is is a fee uh structure and
we try to pair that with um what we're
seeing the parks department and
Municipal um beaches and other
facilities charge and and be on a Level
Playing Field with
that all right so we just got this um
report on your Airport dedicated fund
and it's been growing um significantly
it looks like can you just walk us
through I guess the last year was was
relatively flat but
[Music]
um yeah so over the last few years we
did receive some covid funding um and so
it has grown our cash balances but we've
got some significant Capital
expenditures that we're anticipating um
at the are airport and so we're actually
now just working on our capital budget
and um so I anticipate that over the
next couple of years you're going to see
this uh fund be much lower but yes it
has grown and that's really what it's
been it's
been uh an influx of some of that that
covid funding and
um maybe not some some of the maybe not
some larger internally funded projects
but we've got some um on the horizon
that are going to be internally funded
that are PR significant you can so when
what's the difference between what you
put in the expenses line and in the
other uses line that's really the that
really take that's the increase or
decrease in our receivables and our
grant funding um and
um um
because I'm trying to think what else
could drive that yeah so we're looking
at a point in time um when we're putting
this together so that usually represents
an increase and decrease in pay lables
related to um Grant receipts coming in
or Grant receipts going out and they can
be pretty significant especially like
2024 when we had our terminal Expansion
Project going so when this was pre was
prepared we could have had a grant
reimbursement coming in for a couple
million dollars versus in Prior years
when there was not a lot of big projects
going and in that tracks with 2021 that
was the year that we had reconstructed
our 11,000 ft Runway uh to the tune of
just under $20 million so um the timing
of the grant reimbursement and the grant
allocation uh triggers that large 5.5
million doll other services do you have
a bond for that kind of stuff with the
exception of at the onset of the PDA we
have not bonded um I'm proud to say that
uh We Want To Be A bank's worst worst
customer um and we're very calculated um
we had a it was a decent deal with the
with the US government on the transfer
we have a lot of outdated um buildings
and infrastructure that are coming on to
market now um and we do anticipate for
instance we have to rehabilitate our air
traffic controller which is uh a state a
state asset we have to air traffic
control tower facility build the actual
building has to be uh rehabilitated uh
we have an upcoming believe $4 million
taxiway
Rehabilitation um that that is a primary
egress out to the runway um you you're
dealing with such a large volume of
pavement um was Circa 1950s Era
construction that it it is coming due
and and we anticipate a large um Capital
Pro Plan for for rehabilitation
representative
W I'm on the Sky Haven airport advisory
commission I'm surprised you didn't
mention that that's one of your
responsibilities um you also spend a
fair amount of money there or is that
just what we get from the feds no we we
personally um we we we we do put uh
extensive Revenue into Sky Haven um we
believe it's an incredible general
aviation facility um that has great
economic contribution to the local
region in in Rochester and summersworth
um unfortunately there there is some
competing entities uh for Aviation
around the area um but because of uh
what I would call uh economy of scale um
that we have very talented Prof
professionals at Portsmouth
International Airport that are able to
put their resources to work at Sky Haven
for engineering environmental airport
planning um so we do contribute uh
directly to Sky Haven um and we are now
starting to to to be able to get a
little bit of a Enterprise fund there to
put back in into rehabilit
rehabilitating facilities and just for
the committee should understand that Sky
Haven airport was also transferred to
the PDA approximately
uh mid
mid90s um it was a private airport that
uh was transferred in in to the New
Hampshire dot division of Aeronautics
and then uh essentially it was
transferred to the peace Development
Authority and I I'm proud of the product
up there and uh we hope that it
continues to support the the businesses
uh in in the community in that area we
tried to get Rochester to take it over
but they were unwilling
yeah you were the next y but it seems to
work out right we have you have one
employee we see
regularly thank you and thank you for
your
service all right other
questions
no all right yeah I'm oh I'm sorry
representative lean I didn't see you Mr
chairman so a number of years ago the
state was uh providing some funds and a
bond was taken out to support some
improvements that's all been paid off it
has yes okay
I believe the totality was $10 million
and it has been paid
uh many decade many years ago okay
thanks that's what I thought I just want
to make sure thanks so what fraction of
the 17 million the airport gets every
year comes from the federal
government uh it will so there's two
types of Grant funds that we will'll
receive we'll receive entitlement um
that's basically uh because of the the
number of Passenger Employments that we
have uh that are commercial that that is
about 1 Point for $1.6 million annually
that we'll get because of the numers of
people that utilize the airport and then
we have discretionary and certain bill
or oper type projects specifically um we
had a terminal Federal uh terminal
Improvement to update our passenger
screening our baggage screening um and
those can can fluctuate fortunately
Congressional Delegation uh the
legislature and in and the governor's
office uh usually give us a lot of
support when we go after a grant but it
can vary from from year to year um but
some years we'll only we'll only
recognize that entitlement fund and
other years if there's a specific car
vote that the FAA is trying to promote
specifically improving air tra traffic
control Towers they may come up with a
specific grant for that type of program
and and we certainly would apply and see
how we we gauge throughout the country
for getting that that money but it
varies from year to year so there's no
regular payments from the national
government
or is that the 1.5 million no that's
from the FAA we operate under a joint
use agreement with the Air National
Guard Department of Defense and
essentially that's a cost share um
specifically um we we we signed a
prenuptual ag agreement when we got the
when we received the property um and and
really the key component with the
Department of Defense sh is they provide
the aircraft firefighting and Rescue
Services at peas they also Supply the
labor the air traffic control Personnel
the the the controllers the peas
Development Authority State of New
Hampshire we we are responsible for the
operating and maintenance of the
Airfield um in the airport so um we
identify that those costs over set I
wouldn't want to stand up a fire
department and support the labor and the
resources that have to do with that and
they likely wouldn't want to be
responsible for removing snow um on the
on the runway when they need to be
operational for their mission so we
believe it's a good balance and it's a
good deal for both the federal
government and the state so the bulk of
this is local commercial stuff right I
mean the of the 17
million it's almost all correct it's the
ground it primarily it's the ground
leases that the the non- aeronautical
buildings have generated for instance
six hour facility lans's facilities the
business park it's those ground leases
that are being paid to the peas
Development Authority that is going back
into our Enterprise fund that directly
supports my labor costs my my Capital
Investments my future Capital
Investments and obviously anytime that
we have an opportunity to get Federal
funding we will put an application in
and try to uh utilize money from the
from the federal airport transfer fund
Transportation those leases are probably
long-term correct the majority of if if
if we have a developer that's building
uh or a company that's building a
substantial building we'll try to
amortise that as as long as we can the
FAA has rules on how long that can be so
it's not lay disposal um but we try to
maximize that and and we get we end up
getting a very good building on site is
there much empty land for new commercial
property or not for non- aeronautical
there's not we're down to about four
Parcels uh the easy ones were done first
and the other ones are challenging as
far as site development um so we have
four Parcels remaining that could
potentially be non- aeronautical use um
potentially in the future we could be
more dense you know uh our buildings
could could be higher or expanded that's
a policy decision representative W um
where where do the employees at peas
like all the firefighters and all that
where are they listed so again the the
the fire department would be under the
Department of Defense we get that
service as a joint use agreement cost
share
agreement U my staff peace Development
Authority staff is more maintenance um
equipment
operators um what we call airport
operations agent security agents um so
that's in our onm completely self-funded
by the airport um no impact to to your
general ledger they're not uh classified
or non-classified they're PDA employees
um and we sell fund all all Every salary
associated with the airport a few years
ago I remember something before fiscal
that sticks in my mind because we were
hiring fire
firefighters for a part of a year and
their benefits were greater than their
pay which got my attention but I it most
likely that was under the New Hampshire
Inter National Guards uh budget and
several years ago that was a New
Hampshire International Guard expense
those that fire department has has
transferred to responsibility Department
of Defense Pentagon level um which is a
good story for the state as well and the
commitment that the feds have made in
into peace thank you I wondered what now
thank you do you may see that that on
the next
agency I noticed anyways um yeah so if
everybody if you look at the um airport
fund dedicated fund and see where it
says accounting unit just above the
table and it says off book so that means
it's not in the
book that's what he's talking about yes
right okay um any other questions no all
right well our next one's not scheduled
thank you for coming thank you um our
11:15 um so I guess we have a 20 minute
break
yeah thank
you well should we have a quick C and
happy yeah they seem pretty
money
yes
no what what I want to do is yeah take
10%
off
e
right I recog recognize representative
evil for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make a motion to approve the uh P's
Development Authority budget as
presented I'll second that motion all
right any discussion nope show of hands
in favor looks unanimous excellent
all right all
done all right now um is it right time
yes it is 11:15 we have the special
education
Advocate is that right yeah is advocate
for special come on up all right so for
some reason we only have 15 minutes to
here so please introduce yourself oh we
have this whole present we so we
probably won't have time to go over this
thing I saw this
yesterday I will good morning Kristen
manani Office of the advocate for
special education and my colleague Tim
Lenahan is here with me as well okay so
when we see your budget it's so I'm on
page 109 here um it's one person which I
assume is you and then there's one big
temp that's full-time and that's you is
that right yes yes okay uh
um What's the diff why are we having a
full-time temp as opposed to a full-time
person um we really shouldn't the office
was um just launched kind of when we
were already into the current uh budget
cycle I came on um in the summer of
2023 um so we didn't have any input into
the budget or um you know the creation
of these positions for fulfilling the
statutory duties um there was an
assumption just to give a little bit of
History um when I joined and and um even
from the governor's office Governor
sununu at that point there was an
assumption that we had a handful of
staff to hire and I was pushed you know
constantly to get that process going
with hiring staff um we had some
positions approved redesigned after um a
few months that I was in office uh
interview for them they were advertised
through HR um when it came time to
actually make offers it was discovered
that with the salary scales Etc we
didn't actually have the funding for the
positions um
so we talked to you know there there are
lots of people who would be qualified to
join us um we are we did ask in
prioritize needs for funding for um a
staff of six for the office and what I
did in today's presentation was actually
scale that back to say funding for a
staff of five
myself Mr Lenahan full-time um and not
temp uh and then three other positions
and I'd like to just discuss that
briefly um with the presentation you
have in front of
you um yeah it's very unlikely you know
we're we're so short of money that add
to the governor's budget is is
unrealistic I do understand that what I
would emphasize and and what I've said
throughout this is that I you know we're
asking for positions that have we we are
not asking for an office manager we're
not asking for secretaries we are not
asking for the pr or marketing that some
small agencies also have we are asking
solely for people to do the work case
managers um three for the
32,000 students with IEPs in the state
um our requests for help went up to
about 300 we get on average requests for
help with
30 situations a month 30 to 40 um we are
also pretty actively Consulting with the
legislature at their request and you
know
advancing uh suggestions ourselves with
regard to how the system of special
education um can be improved for both
accountability
and throughout this presentation I've
talked about cost efficiencies that we
can achieve just by having the minimum
Staffing that that we need to do the job
um the state is spending and I'm I'm
sure everyone's heard this discussed um
you know more than $900 million on
special education it's a um definite Hot
Topic we're willing to be very costc
conscious we've taken a really
systemwide approach to looking at um how
with less when it benefits the student
um we have certainly been in positions
to advocate for um less Staffing on
behalf of a parent and student um but
we're we're on the ground we're in the
field doing the work we cannot do the
statutory mandate which has us Data
Tracking doing case management and
resolution across the entire state of
iep's legislative consultation you know
and and pieces um we can't do that with
two people across the entire state so
what brings you into a situation you say
you're doing 30 to 40 IEPs a month but I
mean that's one 1,000th of all the IEPs
that are that's right right so so even
in a year you're doing a 10 1% of all
IEPs right so so for most of IEPs you
have no you never see them right so
that's true yeah so what do you do with
an IEP what what what brings you into
the situation so we get brought into a
situation when um families reject or
partially reject the I AP that's
proposed by their district for the most
part um you know I I was working alone
for the first year did about 40 of these
cases um the 300 that I'm quoting there
you know we're we're not getting to all
of those we're trying to do intake on
all of them but Tim and I with other
responsibilities Beyond just the case
management we can't get to that many um
the situations are pretty dire we've
been triaging you know numbers of
situations where students are out of
school they've been out of school for a
year two years they're hospitalized
they're institutionalized we're getting
them out of those situations you know if
we had families testify we could have
you know U dozens here saying that the
impact to their lives and their
children's lives has been dramatic we
would love to get you know the
investment in special education really
should be an investment in students
performance bringing them up to the
point that they can for the for um
30,000 I would say of the 32,000
students we have on IEPs it should be to
get them to the point where they can
function typically through the
curriculum um and and post graduation
post completion we're we are going to
have you know a thousand plus students
who for whom that's just not possible
they probably will need special
education services their whole lives and
then they will transfer to our
transitions into VC rehab and and you
you know Area Agency supports um we are
for those students really trying to make
sure that there's an integration with
those systems starting in high school um
so that that's efficient um and so that
the resources that exist there really
get used for those students we're
getting more of them positioned for
employment who probably would not have
um again what we're looking for is
funding for for five positions including
the two of us so three additional
um to do on the ground case management
um to
advise uh we're very happy to hear that
Doe has um in place systems for labor
costing um it's going to take a couple
of years to really roll that out but to
figure out by student why are the I
APS um costing as much as they are why
have costs risen um we have a pretty
good sense of that from just literally
looking at IEPs all the time but we'd
love to be involved in that for the
cases we're involved in for just um
checks we've been collaborating with doe
we've been collaborating with private
agencies um we've done trainings for the
New Hampshire Association of special ed
administrators one of the priorities
that would be cost-saving and good for
students that Tim recently did a
training on for them was when we put
students in episodes of treatment or
when we have court ordered placements
how do we keep the education in the
least restrictive environment so that um
what's happening right now is they end
end up coming out of those treatment
episodes or you know being in court
ordered placements in far more
restrictive educational environments
that are also much more costly not great
for the student not good for the system
and they don't return back and that's
because all the right players are not
involved when the court takes over the
placement the schools step back or when
bcbh takes over in an episode of
treatment the schools are stepping back
we're trying to prevent that from
happening so that um we have better
outcomes and and more cost-effective
outcomes that's one tiny measure of ways
we're getting involved systemically but
we need the staff to do it the statutory
mandate can't be done with the two of
us C do you have any kind of statistics
on the the you said you've done 40 or so
cases over the past
year that those I the resulting IEPs are
are somehow less costly overall than
uh so as I said in a number of those
cases we were triaging so students were
home in in situations that weren't legal
right compensatory education was owed so
it's hard to say they're less costly we
have
definitely um in a number of
instances had step down plans again
because I think it's good for students
even as we emphasize cost so we've um
advocated in certain
situations uh to make sure that if a
student was if if we were trying to put
a student in an outplacement from the
district that it was for a limited
period of time subject to evaluations
you know three months out by that you
know different placement and that
everyone on the team was thinking six
months to a year out what do we think
obviously we have to rely on data but
where do we think the step down pieces
are um so we're certainly working with
families on that I would tell you for
the most part um
we're always looking for solutions that
are um good for the students in the
sense that they group you know if it's
an individual speech pathologist why
aren't we doing some group that's
cost-effective it's better for the
student if we have two par Educators
look it doesn't it doesn't make sense we
we don't better serve students by having
two staff who are not as qualified as
perhaps the one staff member we need or
in some instances three so we've
certainly been advocating for that in
instance
um it is too early I think with a lot of
those to say that we've We've Ended up
with IEPs that are less costly because
in a lot of those cases we're really
triaging situations that aren't legal
right we've about 10 of those had to go
to do process hearings to come up with
an outcome um but we're certainly
looking as I said step Downs reassessing
families that we've been involved with
um hammering on progress
reporting which um including a piece of
legislation being Advanced this session
um that would keep people better on
their toes with progress reporting which
is already a requirement but not
happening in a lot of our cases so
accountability um which again the hope
would be that brings
students from support with an IEP
process down to supports with the
multi-tiered system of supports that
that are general education um
um all right so we're running out of
time here so other questions you have
question just really quickly do you ever
get involved with families who think
that they should have an IEP um from the
school and the school doesn't work with
them to develop one we certainly have
been involved in those from time to time
that's the eligibility determination
um I would tell you of the 40 that I
mentioned that I did in the first
year there were only one or two
of those um generally it was students
who and families who'd been involved in
the IEP process for some time um in
those instances I would say to to the
question from representative Maguire
just Brier one of those instances a year
in the family is ready to say that the
services are no longer needed through
the IEP that their student caught up it
was a student who was failing student is
now on the honor role um it was a
specific learning disability eligibility
they had been fighting it for three
years to get any kinds of services and
and that's they're going to be able to
pull off from that so yes we do work on
eligibility identification when it seems
warranted but we're also very conscious
of saying when when it's a limited
specific learning disability when when
can those supports drop back away to a a
more gen Ed in general for an IEP to be
created do the parents have to agree to
it um so there is a default provision in
the statute if if the parents don't
agree and the school does not believe
they can meet the needs of the child
without um those IEP Services um the
there
are they can't provide it initially
right so the very first time a school
can't force a student to become a
special ed student however in subsequent
years um if there are disagreements the
school suggests one thing the parent
disagrees or doesn't respond there are
ways that um Services either stay in
place or can be added by default by the
lack of parent response it can't happen
the very first time um so schools can't
force students into special
education all right representative
Griffin yeah it looks reviewing this
your case load increase it looks like
you're doing like 150 cases a year is
that accurate um we're probably getting
inquiries for close to to 300 um which
is that as representative McGuire said
1% of the students who have IEP
Statewide um we cannot handle that many
so you know I think between the two of
us we can each handle probably 30 to 40
in a year um and that's it but yes we're
getting inquiries for closer to 300 so
at this point 300 a year or 300 BM 300 a
so it takes you more than a week's worth
of work to deal with an
IEP one I mean yes yes I mean most of it
we're we're pretty Hands-On because
these don't come to us until things have
broken down right that we don't get as I
said this is 1% of the 30,000 plus so
when the the IEP team I mean we're often
in a room with you know this many people
each with different disciplines um I I I
don't think one meeting ever resolves
the cases that we get it it tends to be
multiple meetings moving the ball
forward trying to get to resolution and
that is faster and more efficient then
dispute
resolution and a court process like I
said you know we would anticipate that
10% of the 1% of cases that we get
actually need to go to a dispute
resolution process through doe that
involves tons of time for everyone um it
is sometimes beneficial it gets kids out
of hospitalization into appropriate
programs which by the way is actually
less costly even though their programs
may be very costly it is less so than
institutionalization and and more
appropriate um yes
the uh just just getting through the
documents for a couple of years to
understand the case and why there's a
dispute would take a significant time
never mind the team meetings um and then
obviously cases that go further
require more so why does why does your
2027 is that right or is that marketing
no that's travel
yeah it should we'd allocate it from
somewhere different both Tim and I do
travel
um quite a bit if you had more employees
would you scatter them around the state
um we would we'd probably try to do
something that was more um developed
towards expertise in certain areas Tim
tends to handle more that is a court
ordered placement um or episode of
treatment pieces he has a background as
a jppo whereas I handle some that are um
really broken down educational um
environments my background is more in
education uh but so we'd probably do it
less geographically and more by subject
matter all right well our our time is up
but I'm I'm going to like to ask you
back um at some point um maybe next week
you all right we now have page 110 the
next
page very easy
now
to take this out I'm not going to be
all right welcome good morning my name
is Cassandra Sanchez I'm the child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
attorney Lisa massio I am the associate
child advocate and our legislative and
policy
director so in our handout here we have
for you a bit about the mission of our
office um and I'll just Briefly
summarize this here for you so our
office um was established in 2018 as
oversight over our child welfare agency
specifically um child welfare and
Juvenile Justice both DCF in 2020 we
received expanded jurisdiction and at
that time we um expanded to jurisdiction
over all child serving executive branch
agencies and any entity that contracts
or certifies with them to provide direct
treatment to Children the role of our
office is to ensure that the best
interests of New Hampshire's children
are protected and a lot of the focus of
our work still is directly of the
oversight over our child welfare in
juven Justice agency um we do have touch
points as well with residential
treatment which is housed um also a DHHS
service but housed under the Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health um but
again the majority of of the daily work
that we receive and do in the office is
tied to the oversight over our child
welfare agency um we are fully staffed
in the office we have nine full-time
positions um one is classified which is
my position the remainder is
unclassified the remainder of the the
positions on page three for you I have a
bit of data about um the incidents and
inquiries that our office reviews um our
inner reporting time frame is from July
1st through June 30th so we match the
fiscal year cycle um within that last
fiscal year we received
2937 incident reports for review every
single one of those reports are reviewed
in
its entirety and um some of them have
more in-depth reviews those would be the
critical incident reports which um there
were 86 of them within that time
frame the uh 1500 there are restraint
and seclusion reports we do review those
in full and we reach out if there is an
issue on them um the critical incident
reports we review we do our own internal
summary and we track to follow um next
steps for safety of those children what
does it mean to be a critical incident
report yes that's a great question a
critical incident report is includes a
family that's involved with our um
department for children youth and
families and it is when there is an
issue of serious harm to a child a child
fatality a parent fatality um as well as
a serious incident um that could be out
in the media um and identifies that the
family is related to that
system and so we received those reports
directly from DCF indicating the
incident that occurred in the action
steps there taking to protect either the
child directly impacted or surviving
siblings if it is a child
fatality um citizen complaints also come
to our office we had 349 that we managed
in that last fiscal year um and of those
349 with that means is that we respond
to every single one of them um some of
them then require further casework and
follow up by the udman in our office
others of those um are referral to other
services but all of those do require man
hours to respond to and we do not leave
any calls unanswered to our office um
you will see on the next slide it talks
about comp time earned so we changed to
a new um management system for payroll
um starting on November 1st and at that
time um the
system oh that's sorry typo there that
is 2024 um within that that time frame
so be between November 1st and the last
pay period this is the amount of comp
time earned by staff throughout our
office and this means this is time that
they have worked beyond their regular
work hours to get the work done to
ensure that everything is entered into
the system is processed and is reviewed
timely for the safety of children um so
with the Staffing we have now this just
shows how we are very limited capacity
and are putting in extra hours to ensure
that we get the work done so these
numbers are hours or days it is comp
time so it is not direct hours um I can
say for the assistant child Advocates
and the associate child advocate those
are direct hours for the legal aid there
are certain hours that um calculate at a
higher rate of a 1.5 versus a one a
single hour so it's harder to get the
breakdown of that information um so we
just included it as comp time earned um
we are working to do some internal work
to really bring that down to ours to
understand what that means um but for
those them all the other positions other
than a legal aid they are direct hours
that's an hourly rate okay is there uh
overtime in your budget we did put in
our prioritize need overtime for this um
fiscal year we had not had an overtime
fund prior so when we did switch over to
the new system the only option was to
allow staff to collect comp
time and there's one fewer
employee so the one fewer in our budget
um if you go back to the breakdown on
page two um we note there that our final
position which is an office coordinator
position has been unfunded in in the
budget we had to unfund a position to be
able to meet our our minimum um budget
number given by the prior governor and
in this Governor's budget um she
included funding for all positions but
this one position which is our office
coordinator we had to select a position
at the time to meet the the numbers so
we selected a position that was vacant
at that time that position has been
filled since and is critical to the
functions of our office manages our
purchasing and procurement um assists
with the budget development and so it is
critical to the Daily functions of the
office we have added that to our
prioritized needs to seek that position
being refunded for our office and it is
we did move it up higher and our
prioritize needs because of that so if
you before we get to that um the
following two charts that I have for you
here um show the at point in time as of
Fe feary 18th the amount of open
inquiries with our office right now um
then these are the assignments per staff
member how many they each are carrying
including myself carrying a small case
load of six to be able to make sure we
are meeting the need of our constituents
and then our critical incidents um open
as of that same date there are 255 open
um and what I can share is um that the
reason that some of them linger longer
particularly if it's a child fatality um
we are requesting information from from
an autopsy we also review if there is
any um legal investigation what has
played out with that so there are times
where those will linger open longer um
but we are still actively working on
them throughout that time period so
what's your what action would you take
in the case of a fatality wouldn't that
be up to the police to deal with it the
police do take action at time we do
review what they have done but the Child
Welfare agency is responsible for any
surviving siblings so the immediate work
that we are doing while we are waiting
whatever processes may be taking place
whether it be law enforcement uh or um a
court process we are reviewing what the
agency has done to ensure safety of the
remaining siblings and um we are also
conducting reviews about what the
involvement was at the time of the
fatality and whether there are
recommendations for a child welfare
agency to do things differently in the
future to avoid these incidents from
continuing to happen so let's suppose
the
that situation occurred that that that
you think that whatever dcyf did in this
case is wrong do you have the authority
to order them to do something different
or not we do not have the authority to
order them we make recommendations to
the agency we meet with the agency
internally and we also report out
publicly on findings that we have if we
are feeling that there is a serious
safety concern that the agency is not
responding to that is when we would
bring it to um The public's attention to
make sure it is very transparent and
clear um what missteps we identified and
what recommendations we are making and
we also um meet with the legislature as
well around any potential legislative
changes that could impact the safety of
children okay all right go ahead um so
yes our first prioritize need here is um
refunding our office coordinator
position um the pay and benefits that
are listed there are the pay and
benefits before we had the current staff
and their role and it was something
somebody who had been in the position
for quite some time so they were on the
highest end of paying benefits um we
have tried to work with our HR to get
more accurate numbers um but they do
they did not have them in time for this
presentation um but we do believe that
the pay and benefits for this position
would actually be reduced with the newer
position we are also asking our
prioritize needs for an additional
assistant child's Advocate position
because of the um High case load number
and now leading to um longer lag times
of getting back to folks when they're
calling in a concern to our office um we
also noted that not only are the case
loads high but the cases have become
more intensive which result in us
meeting on them over longer periods of
time where when I first came into the
office we typically have one or two
meetings conclude and we would close the
case and move on now we have cases that
have been open for a year plus I see so
let me just tell you that you know we we
have no EXP money we have less than what
the governor thinks we have and so the
chance of of adding is is uh negligible
uh let me ask you about something in the
budget specifically um line page 110
class
17 uh full-time employee special
payments do you know what that is I do
not know what that is actually that was
not in the budget that we submitted that
came in the governor's budget and I've
not been able to get an answer about
what that is okay Melissa or Jack yeah
so that's time acred so once the person
left that's their time acral that gets
paid
out but why is it both years wouldn't it
just
year yeah I'll look into it okay fine
all right good now other questions from
committee
members
I'm looking at your hand out here and
um if I can find the spot
again um received reviewed and responded
to and monitored M
349 citizen
complaints what is what is the
respondant to how do you respond to
those complaints it differs depending on
the complaint they are individualized um
what are response may look like but many
of times we are directly reaching out to
the Child Welfare agency about their
work on the case and making either
direct recommendations to um ensure
safety of the children on the case or
asking questions about what they are
doing to ensure safety if it's not
clearly identified within their system
we do have direct access into their um
electronic case management system so we
always start by reviewing that and what
they have detailed there and then we
will reach out to them we do then
respond back to the constituent caller
because a lot of this information is
confidential we cannot necessarily share
the direct outcome but we can share that
we addressed it with the agency and we
feel that they're now taking the
appropriate steps to ensure
safety yes um what's the RSA that adds
21v I have a copy here if you'd like it
questions if I may share one update if
you look at the final slide we are
looking at other ways in which um we
could reduce our budget we um have begun
talking with Das about the current space
that we have and looking to leverage
work from home schedules to reduce the
amount of office space we have so that
we're paying less to um Das for plant
and property we had a reorg a on our um
in our prioritized needs we've now
bumped that down um to the bottom
recognizing that it's not um that the
budget is very tight and that's not
realistic in this time frame so we are
we are trying to get creative and look
at other opportunities to cost save for
our agency and we're planning some
future meetings um with folks from Das
to come over to our space to look at
what it looks like now and how much the
cost saving would be to reduce to half
of the offices that we have currently is
Johnson Hall off Pleasant Street is that
one yes yeah near labor and all those
people yeah okay good thank you uh
representative
evil just looking at uh your statement
under prioritized needs it says other
line items operating expenses I mean
what you say here is without additional
funds the office will not be able to pay
for basic needs in order to fulfill our
mandates related directly to children's
safety and
well-being
um so you're really struggling to
fulfill your mandate at this point with
the level of funding that you have we
are not with the 2025 budget um that is
very reasonable amount that we can work
within if you look at the following
slides it actually shows you um the the
breakdown of the budget in this climate
and it shows that 93% of our budget in
efficiency is paid to pay and benefits
and so that leaves us a 2% operating
budget that does not allow us enough
money to get out to see children we
travel out of state to see children we
travel across the state to meet with
them it is part of our mandate to meet
with them in person as needed um that
would greatly reduce the ability to do
that um we do visit uh YDC and Hamstead
Hospital both on a monthly basis we
would have to cut that down
significantly maybe to twice a year um
so th it's because the op so much of our
our budget currently is paying benefits
that we would not have the operating
budget like we have now um and we do
have a a chart um on one of the
following Pages showing what it is in
2025 and then what the dip is um for
operating budget in the next
years which which page there's a bunch
of py graphs um it's after the two py
graph Pages the bar graph following that
bars I think with they're talking about
this here on page
111 um in fiscal year 25 there's 27
,000 of uh travel turning to to seven
and then five right so
yeah all
right
no I don't see any more questions so
thank you very much thank you for
coming okay all right so we are going to
come back at 1:15 and this
afternoon we have um uh Dr we can ask
them those other questions uh State and
labor hopefully those are relatively
think
e
137 I like to get the big picture of who
and we have commissioner steep here
correct good afternoon Lindsay step
commissioner at the Department of
Revenue Administration with me is
Shelley gerano our business
administrator you have before you a
presentation which I just need to pull
okay and so just a reminder on page two
of the presentation what the mission of
the department
is
we um our mission is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due in
incurring the least cost to taxpayers in
a manner that merits the highest degree
of public confidence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in the matters of
Budget Finance and the appraisal of real
estate page three of our presentation is
our current fiscal year 24 fiscal year
25 org chart we have have
153 authorized full-time
positions 118 of those are classified 35
are
unclassified and then you can see the
breakdown between our Administration
unit so the total is the same but a few
have moved around round is that right
that's right you'll have one position
that moved from the taxpayer Services
Division and one and that moved from
taxpayer Services into collections in
the fiscal year 2627 budget but yes the
total number how many of these are
unfunded or unfilled or we will'll get
four so as you said Mr chair this is
kind of the big picture of the
department you have your fiscal year
2024 actual expense your fiscal year
2025 adjusted authorized and then 26 and
27 for the
governor the majority of our department
is General funded um education trust
fund money is solely for the low and
moderate income property tax relief
program and agency income is a
combination of flood control which we
pay to the municipalities who were
impacted by the mar the damning of the
marac and Connecticut rivers and then
also The Debt Service on the bonds that
were used used to pay for our Revenue
information management
system so again you can see that the
position count Remains the
Same um from 24 all the way through
27 I would note our general fund is 70%
salary and benefits we are a department
of people not programs or
things you will see there is a
difference between fiscal year 24 actual
in fiscal year 25 adjusted authorized
that's due to a a couple of things first
at the end of fiscal year 24 we had a
vacancy rate of 16 A5 per. so was 17 70%
of our budget being salary and benefits
and a vacancy rate of almost
177% there was a pretty decent impact to
our budget as with um unfilled
positions when you then look from 24 and
you kind of skip 25 and you look to 26
and 27 you will see an increase there
that is largely due to us needing to
operate rationalize the cost of
supporting our rims system so as a
reminder rims was a$3 Million
$160,000 Capital
appropriation that Capital money is in
the process of running out the project
has been in place for seven years um and
so we have known for seven years that at
this point we will need to start
operationalizing those expenses and
moving those expenses from the capital
budget into our operating budget I'll
talk more about that when we get to
those actual line items and explain in
more detail what that means thank
you um current funded position count as
we mentioned is
153 the efficiency request that we put
forward would fund 135 positions that
was uh almost 12% reduction the
governor's budget funds
129 positions so we um the governor's
budget is a 15
7% reduction in our funded positions all
of those positions that are unfunded are
currently
vacant okay moving on to page five
before just a couple so there there's a
a handful of vacant ones that are that
are funded correct and we're going to
talk about those in detail um when we
get to those accounting units so before
we go through each of the accounting
units um I just wanted to say that I
will not note as the chair requested any
remaining vacant positions that are
funded in the governor's budget we'll go
through those I'm also going to
highlight other non salary and benefit
changes between 24 25 26 and
27 um I have included as the chair
requested some areas for additional
savings that are Beyond salary and
benefits spoiler alert they're small but
I did we did scrub the budget and tried
to find everything that we could um
what you'll see on page five before we
get into the individual accounting units
these are areas um current expense
equipment training and instate and out
of state travel we um made changes to
all of these areas in all of the
accounting units so rather than talking
about them repetitively I just kind of
wanted to preface up front you will see
a reduction in class 20 in current
expense across many of the accounting
units and that is due to just having
fewer employees and also reducing our
postage um because of the repeal of the
interest in dividends tax you will see
across all the accounting units a
reduction in equipment um we upgraded
our fleet of cars that we use for our
Municipal and property division our
audit division and our collections
division we did that in 24 and
25 um so our Fleet is modern they are
hybrid vehicles so we anticipate fewer
repair costs and fewer um less money
spent on gas we also decreased training
and travel um so these amounts were
right sized due to the reduction in the
number of employees so that's across all
of the accounting units and again just
to be efficient I wanted to cover them
up
front so if you want to go back to page
126 Mr chair if you're ready okay you
can kind of start at the top this is or
organized in order by accounting unit
and hopefully I hit on um any of the
significant changes so first is the
administration accounting
unit first class to note is class 22
you'll see an increase there um this is
rental for our multifunction printers we
moved the payment from one printer that
was being paid out of taxpayer services
and we moved it into administ
so it's a reduction in One AU and an
increase in another in class 26 this is
just an anticipated year-over-year
increase in membership dues for National
Organ organizations that we utilize um
as tax administrators and also
Cooperative audit programs why don't we
skip numbers less than a 100,000 just to
sure um unless we ask about them but you
know I'm more interested in class 27
sure let's talk about class 27
so as I mentioned we need to
operationalize um the the costs for
rims and as I said this has been coming
for a number of years um we knew that we
would need to do this it's
understandably I understand it somewhat
unfortunate given the budget picture
that this would be the year that we
would need to start um absorbing these
costs but it is what it is in terms of
timing so these are ongoing payments to
the vendor for for maintenance and and
service or is it um still paying off the
equipment so and software good question
so it is let's see one two three four
five
things um first we currently have
Hardware um and we are currently paying
Hardware support that is physical
Hardware that sits at 27 Hazen drive and
is at end of life so we will be
transitioning to the
cloud and the amounts to do that um are
included in here we also have
Baseline vendor support and or I should
say software support this is your
patches um your just ongoing support
associated with running the
software then we have um additional
support that we um utilize in the form
of time and material materials so the
vendor has packaged support they call it
level two support or level three
support we decided not to opt into a set
level of support because I wanted to be
confident that we were getting what we
were paying for and you don't always get
what you pay for when you pick a
prepackaged um software support so we
instead utilize a time and materials so
we only pay for the services that we
receive and so these are um it's an
hourly rate for the individuals that
provide the
services we have been in the process of
decreasing the amount of people that we
utilize um when the project was in Full
full swing there were 30 vendors on site
every day um as I think I mentioned
previously they moved here they moved
here with their families they lived here
in conquered in the surrounding town
pounds once the project was over we
started decreasing um we went down to 8
we are currently at six and this budget
has us at four so I have done what I can
in order to reduce the number um I will
also say that this vendor has been great
to work with in terms of cross trining
and knowledge transfer to our embedded
doit staff um so we have our own staff
working on the project as well so we're
not solely relying in on vendor support
um we're making sure that our people
know um how the software runs as well
can your new can local staff make
feature changes or is that only the time
and materials kind of thing so what the
time and materials cover so the level
run support as I said will cover the
patches and you know the usually twice a
year for this vendor um and then what
the time and materials will cover is um
they will assist us we will do it
cooperatively with any request to the
functionality so if we need things
changed um that's done in consultation
and working alongside with the vendor
when we need to do an upgrade which we
don't because we just upgraded but in
the future when we need to do an upgrade
that's when you really need to pull in
the vendor to do much of that
work okay um and then the only there's
two other small things just to be
thorough that are included in this
amount um we do pay the vendor $50,000 a
year for 24/7 monitoring it's a tax
system we want people to be able to make
payments when they want to make payments
even if it's the on the middle of a
night on a Saturday night um so we pay
the vendor to make sure our system is up
at all times and we also utilize um the
vendor for a data subscription um to
assist us with correcting um wrong
addresses um so we can make sure that we
get the information out to the
taxpayers do you know that more than 50
,000 in taxes comes in between 8:00 p.m.
and 8:00 a.m. or something like that you
know what I mean I actually I should
look at that it probably would depend on
the on the day of the month I imagine um
right before the 15th there's fair
amount of of things that happen a lot of
folks um I think the taxpayers that most
appreciate making sure that they can
make payments 24 hours a day or our
meals and rentals operators they're
making a payment every month restaurant
might not closed till 10: p.m. and
they're sitting there doing the books
after that so okay very good um so that
is is the largest um increase now in
2024 are you saying there was some still
some capital budget money that went into
that correct so there was still Capital
Money in 24 there's a little bit of
capital money in 25 it's really 26 and
27 where we're full operationalizing so
we've been spending 6 and5 million a
year on these items for a long time
correct even more than that because our
time in materials I was at eight people
and I was at six people this is four
gotcha so yeah we've been spending even
even more than that all right thank
you
um other changes within
Administration uh line 43 line 43 Debt
Service so um this is on the bottom
bullet of page six so these are
principal and interest payments on the
bonds that were used to fund rims so
again $30 M60 th000 6 million of that
principal and interest was paid by the
general fund the remaining
$4,160
th000 is paid for through Revenue uplift
from rims so we at the department
transfer up to $4 million a year a
revenue uplift into a dedicated fund
that's used to pay the principal and
interest so you will see in class 43 The
Debt Service amounts if you move
down to 99 agency income you'll see
those amounts are offset 100% so the
agency income is the dedicated fund
paying The Debt Service of class
43 oh I see and those amounts are given
to us by treasury based on the bond
schedule um that they issued and the and
the reason that this B anum's numbers
are so much bigger than last is because
some of these bonds have just been
issued correct so they right they issue
the bonds my understanding is that they
issue the bonds in in the time timely
manner to make the payments yes so yes
we have there are more bonds that are
requiring principle and interest this by
you um if you look at class 46 you will
see nothing um in fiscal year 24 you'll
see almost half a million dollars in 25
and then a dollar in 26 and 27 this is
the removal of one of the Consultants
that we were using um for rims so there
was no cost in 24 we have some money
budgeted in 25 but then it's essentially
eliminated in 26 and 27 as we reduced
the number that was necessary
gotcha um any other lines that you want
to cover in the administration unit
it no I think the only other one I guess
worth noting is the transfers uh class
89 the transfers to the D maintenance
fund that's something new in 26 and
89 oh so okay what's that so those are
amounts given to us um by D I believe
because we are in a building that's
owned by Das and we're paying rent this
is the establishment of a m main fund
gotta so that is something new okay and
then on page seven just to cover the um
there's two positions well one directly
in an ad in the administration unit um
and one that's a path pass through from
doit but we have two positions that are
funded in the governor's budget but are
currently vacant I'll skip to the um
business systems analyst I believe
commissioner goule um when he spoke to
you the other day mentioned this
position I believe he is in support of
unfund of um unfund that position it is
currently vacant and we would Echo that
sentiment we're fine to unfund that
position the paralal um as I mentioned
here on the slide this is the only paral
paralal in our legal Bureau our legal
Bureau is two attorneys so as I like to
say they're kind of lean and mean for uh
a Revenue Agency um the position became
vacant in the fall we did some initial
recruitment which was not successful um
we have since pulled down the
recruitment um and would like to
consider reposting that position in the
spring when we get a waiver from the
governor's office it is a pretty
critical position um and so I would
request that that one remain funded if
possible
yeah okay just to be sure thorough on
page eight oh sorry so there's a
business analyst 2 and a business anal
three or those the same thing I'm sorry
that's probably a typo it is a business
systems analyst two two okay so that's
so it's the second one in the box that
you want you think can be correct and
that is actually like I said in Do's
budget but it comes through to us in our
you page eight just to be thorough we
included workers comp and unemployment
compensation not much to note there
on page nine of the presentation and
Page
129 of the governor's budget is the
division of taxpayers services where was
128 oh there it is
yeah so was just 25 just wrong or is
it um 25 we may not is there sufficient
money in that line we do have a we are
paying workers comp at this time and
that's probably insufficient to cover
what we will need for the
year which is why it went up for 26 and
27 yeah because we've seen certain
agencies their workers comp as as
ballooned but yours it seems about the
same fingers crossed it seems maybe tax
is less dangerous then yeah I mean maybe
it's it's it's uh you don't lay off as
many or something
anyway all right okay taxpayer Services
page
129 there are not really terribly
significant changes here I would just
note um class
103 which is the
contracts for other services you'll see
it was um actual in 24 was just under
50,000 the budget for 25 is
100,000 and then it drops to 85 and 65
essentially in 26 and 27 this is the
line that we would utilize for temporary
services that we may need during our
busy Seasons to make sure that we get
our documents processed in a timely
manner our staffing levels were
sufficient in Fairly sufficient in 24 we
didn't need wouldn't have needed much um
so we did reduce in 26 and 27 but with
the UNF funding of all of our vacant
positions in taxpayer Services there may
be a need for those sorts of
services so this is the part that
answers the phones right is it um so
some of these folks will answer the
phones um they also will do all of our
processing so they process all of the
mail all of the payments they perform
all of the account
maintenance um necessary so these are
the folks that kind of
run the ship most of the most of the day
so there's a fair number of un un vacant
positions in this area correct on the
last bullet on page nine the governor's
budget UNF funds eight tax examiner twos
and one tax examiner three so we have
nine positions that are unfunded in the
governor's budget that is all of the
currently vacant positions and that's
mostly due to indd going away that you
can manage I'm hoping we can manage um
that's why I did kind of want to
highlight that that class 103 where we
may need temporary services I'm hopeful
that we don't we will know better um in
May because we will need we will be
receiving interest and dividends tax
returns this
April and so um we will be doing that
with a reduced staff but to your point
I'm confident more confident going
forward with the elimination of that tax
that we don't need as many positions as
we've had in the past how many returns
did it generate um interest in dividends
tax would be somewhere between 70 and
85,000 returns more in the last year
because interest rates were higher we
had a lot of firsttime filers um but if
you look back a few years ago it was
probably closer to 70,000 and and the
bulk of those would be online all
automatic is that right or not this is
actually our um cohort that really
prefers the paper forms we get the
largest number of paper form forms um
from this group a lot of people um will
prepare them themselves um it's more of
our business tax filers that utilize the
the online filing and how many of those
are there that's probably closer to 75
to 880,000
filers so it's almost the same number in
some years and some of them are are
meals and rooms also and some aren't is
that correct so some business tax filers
will also have a monthly meals and rooms
obligation those are primarily filed
online um because there is a requirement
in statute that if the amount that
you're due to pay is over a certain
amount and you want to retain your
commission you have to file
electronically
and uh business taxes are quarterly
quarterly estimates and then a return or
extension in March or April and then if
you make an extension payment then
you're um you have a seven-month
extension to file your full return into
the fall meals and rooms monthly monthly
yeah okay yeah so that's why you
need you need more people in this
department for those per return right
because you're getting more volume
correct yeah okay yep thank
you um so I believe those are the
highlights of taxpayer Services unless
there's anything else that you want to
cover any questions I'm not seeing hands
so we'll keep going um audit division
starts at the bottom of page
um there's the most significant thing to
talk about here outside of positions is
the instate and outof state travel lines
mostly the out ofate travel line you
will see we spent just under 100,000 or
just under 990,000 excuse me in fiscal
year 24 but our adjusted authorized for
25 is
300,000 um that was because we have a
number of vacant positions we were
hoping that we were going to fill some
of those positions and when we do fill
those positions Auditors travel in pairs
as that new employee is trained and
brought up to speed so without new
employees we didn't need to spend as
much that's been reduced from the 312
down to 100,000 in 26 and
27 is the lack of these Auditors costing
Revenue potentially I mean each auditor
does bring in money um I'm confident
though that in the Auditors that we do
have and in the management of that
division that they're managing to make
sure that we have as much compliance as
possible um this this um the house and
both the Senate in Prior years have
added positions um and just we have not
been able to recruit for them
successfully oh so the ones I think we
added three of the Multistate Auditors
yes our highest level Auditors and and
so those were never filled I see well
that might change with the layoffs at
the IRS last week maybe there's some
federal employees that I could uh that I
could hire at this point so if if such a
person became available then you could
ask the governor to unfreeze that
position potentially and so right now
the governor's budget does
unfund um nine positions which are two
tax field auditor ones those are um are
more of our inate Auditors two multi-
entity tax Auditors those are more of
your like New England Regional business
type Auditors and five of those
multi-state tax Auditors there are four
additional vacant positions that remain
funded two tax field auditor ones a tax
auditor one that just became vacant last
week and I did include that um and then
there is one multi-state tax auditor
that is still filled so if to your point
if that position
remained funded then yes I could proceed
to ask the governor um for a waiver and
fund that position so I thought we
decided that these unfunded ones were in
the taxpayer
services not the Auditors we have them
across the board oh okay I see they're
in every division except collections
because it's fully staffed got yeah no
we have unfunded Auditors currently in
the governor's budget so let's go go
back um
the total number un funded
something I think it's 24 in the
governor's
budget I see 24 yes in total I got so so
they're scattered all around yeah I
understand thank you 18 in our
efficiency and then the governor added
right
okay um this is mentioned at the end um
but I will note the and we talked about
this when I was here previously there's
a provision that you're probably aware
of in the governor's um trailer bill
that would allow um us to potentially
fill unfunded positions so long as we
stayed within our budgeted amount and so
Mr chair to your point we would look to
these multi-state tax Auditors because
these are the ones that do bring in the
most money um so those would be a
priority to fill if we were able to even
if they're unfunded if I can make the
math work that would be an area that I'd
be looking to so basically these these
out ofst State companies they're just
getting audited instead of every two
years it's every three years or might be
a little bit longer correct correct I
mentioned previously too that we pay
some organizational dues to some
national organizations and part of those
is for some Cooperative auditing um and
so that is a way to
that um one of those organizations is
called The multi-state Tax Commission
and they will go and audit very large
companies for a number of states at the
same time so we don't need to send our
own Auditors they kind of audit on our
behalf send us the results and we wrap
it up with the taxpayer so there are
ways that we're still ensuring
compliance even if we don't have all of
these positions filled do we when we do
an audit do we share it with those
people and we get some kind of credit I
wish I wish we will do some Regional
sharing um we have agreements with
Massachusetts Maine New Hampshire
Vermont Connecticut so that we can kind
of share if we're seeing things on audit
and it might be something that another
state would be interested in and they'll
share that same information with us all
right great um one bit of I think
housekeeping hopefully on page
11 there is an error in the governor's
budget where a position is listed as
vacant and it's currently
filled and the position that's vacant is
listed as filled so we have them the
wrong way around we've spoken with the
LBA about this I believe what we just
need is um this committee to approve
making this edit and then it will get
corrected going forward so Jack will
make an amendment for us yeah perfect
thank
you on page 12 this is the collection
Division and this is on page
131 starts on page 131 of the governor's
budget um relatively small division this
is where you will see there is an
increase in the
headcount from 24 and 25 to 26 and 27 we
did move a position from another from
the taxpayer services division in
here um there's not a whole lot to talk
about in this division but we did
identify
a couple of areas where we felt like we
could make a small reduction the first
is to the current expense line uh class
20 we would be comfortable with a $3,000
reduction in 26 and a $2,000 reduction
in 27 again it's small but I wanted to
make sure that um make them both
six, that would bring them both down to
six I believe that's correct okay so
Jack make a
not um what is the land Acquisitions
okay so that is where we pay for our
filing fees for our leans so when we are
kind of at the tail end of collection
activities we will lean um property It's
very effective it tends to get taxpayers
attention quite quickly in all honesty
and I think we've talked about this
previously we are um typically very
willing to release those leans um and
work with the taxpayer um to make sure
that they can enter into a payment plan
and resolve um their debt without
actually um garnishing their property um
so this is another place where we could
reduce um 10,000 a reduction of 10,000
in each year um so it would go from
48,000 in each year to
38,000
okay this division has no vacant
positions currently um it was fully
staffed um all along so there's no
um reductions in positions to this this
thank next on page 13 of the
presentation and Page 133 of the
governor's budget is the municipal and
property
Division I wanted to talk about class
38 you will see the fiscal year
24 actual is 252,000 that goes up to 38
4 and 25 then to 350 and 300 and 26 and
27 I just wanted to note that that
252 um really would be
325 roughly there was $775,000
in bills from the vendor um which we
paid in fiscal year 25 that was for work
that was done in 24 that was due to
issues in Billing on the vendor part and
in all honesty I withheld payment until
I was confident that the bills were
correct so that's why there was the
delay so it's more flat than so it's
essentially more flat and that 350 and
300 reflects um the contract amendment
that we're currently in but it looked
like we were increasing and we're really
not I
understood um CL control sure sorry
flood control flood control
okay how much do you want to talk about
flood control um so this has been a
topic as you'll remember over the
years 26 and 27 assumes that
Massachusetts will reimburse their share
of the 70% of the marac and 50% of the
Connecticut and Connecticut will
reimburse their 40% share of the
Connecticut compact as you know there's
been a history of lack of payment so we
received just under 3.5 million as a
settlement for fiscal years 15 to 21 we
received just under a million dollar for
fiscal year 22 and 23 we are owed just
under a million dollars for 24 and 25
but have not received payment
yet however I understand that these
commissions are actively talking there
is work being done it's not um kind of
the radio silence that we saw in the
past but there are outstanding amounts
um that are
due do we ever take them to court or
that's how we've gotten those
settlements y I see yep but maybe it
costs that much to go to court right
right or do we have people on staff the
Attorney General's office usually helps
us negotiate that um in the past so that
and the um the attorney at the Attorney
General's office who handled that has
been monitoring the progress yeah so so
the so it's completely unknown I guess
okay all right um land taxes lost okay
so this is not one that we talk about
often but I will just mention it briefly
because I think this is an area where we
could have um just a small reduction so
this is essentially reimbursing um towns
for money that off for state and federal
forests where they don't receive um tax
revenue because it is owned by either
the state or the federal government um
these amounts do fluctuate year toe so
you'll see the 24 spense was just about
$770,000 but our adjusted authorized in
25 is 98,000 and then it goes to 95 for
26 and
27 um it's been as high as 990,000 in
the past 5 years with the increases that
many municipalities are seeing in their
tax rates I suspect that that 70,000 is
going to be more in the coming years but
we could drop that 95,000 down to 90 in
each year if if the committee wanted
there's $5,000 in each year there that
we could reduce do you know what the RSA
is for this o not off the top of my head
but we can maybe Jack can find out
yeah because do we do this for other
things like the State House complex for
example it's just I think state and
federal Forest is has always been my
understanding of it um and I don't know
if that was part of
the negotiation when the White Mountain
National Forest for instance um you know
came to
be I'm not sure typically
for like a municipality like for the
State House complex or you know any
college or university or other nonprofit
they'll enter into a payment and Le of
taxes with the town at the municipal
level but I guess since this is you know
larger amounts of state and federal land
um it comes from the state to to help
okay um page 135 and 136 we have the
current use board and the assessing
assessing Standards Board these are
boards administratively attached to us
and all that you're seeing there is some
per DM rates and travel reimbursement
the amounts are pretty
flat on page
137 you have the low and
moderate um income tax relief program
this is funded out of the education
trust
fund um we're just just over 1.1 million
in 24 and then we're flat from 25 to 27
at 1 and A5 million um the amounts of um
that property owners can
receive and the income limitations were
adjusted in
2021 um and so we saw some increase
amount of payments there let's find out
the RSA for this one also Jack um that I
probably
have oh you do um no that was chapter
law
98 there's so many of these kind of
things you know there's optional ones
given all kinds of this was for swept
for swept I see right it is it
reimburses them for the amount of swept
that they
paid yeah that they don't
pay nobody pays Sweat Right um I don't
have that off the top of my head but um
can't right right stays local 100%
right it's 100% fake okay we'll talk
about that some other time all right um
and then just on on the I think that's
should be the end of our budget and just
on the last page of the presentation
page 17 I did highlight two sections
from the governor's trailer Bill the one
that I mentioned was the ability to fill
unfunded positions if the total
expenditures do not exceed the
appropriation for personnel and benefits
that was something I had talked about
this committee with when I was here
previously um and I think given that the
at least with the governor's budget
count was going to go down to
129 our headcount has hovered around
150 since
2012 we have not grown
significantly um so
so I'm confident that we can do it we
have a lot of dedicated employees but
certainly flexibility to make sure that
you know we could fill positions if we
had the money um would be appreciated
you have a brand new computer yes true
no that and it is true and we've
certainly gained efficiencies from that
system as well um and I think the the
current headcount will test that we can
make it all happen um and then just on
the other section there's a change to
the distribution of funds in the
governor's budget essentially the split
of funds between the general fund and
the education trust fund for the two
business taxes the tobacco's tax and the
real estate transfer tax and that's no
problem for us to administer because of
our it that's certainly going to be
moving around so no question about that
it is our computer system allows us to
make that change relatively easily so no
concerns if that amount um continues to
move what about the excess swept there's
a Bill to um actually collect that right
right there that um I believe there's a
fiscal note attached to that um
requesting some funding if if that
excess swept were to be collected by the
department and then distributed back out
um you know I don't think the I think
the amount might have been around
$100,000 but don't quote me because I
don't have it in front of me um but it
our system would be able to do that with
the program pramming um it would the
towns would log in and they would log in
just like any other taxpayer and it
would put them through a process um to
do that um fairly easily I think once
it's developed it would be easy to
maintain oh so you could debit their
bank account or that would be nice if
they let us they can if they give us the
information we'll take the money I see
okay now there's there's kind of two
ways to do that one bill I've seen says
have them send in the excess for the for
the handful of towns
that have one other bills I've seen says
every town send the whole thing and then
we will you know send our part and
there's some advantages to that as
having to do with timing because the
time they collect is not necessarily the
time that we pay our corre adequate Ed
right so correct um would that be a lot
more work or or from your point of view
is one of those better than the other or
so I misheard when you spoke previously
I think the $100,000 is to do it for
everybody I see the excess swept I think
we could probably AFF effectuate that
because that's a handful of towns um I
think it's could still be 30 or
something 30 so the the price tag on
that is probably a little bit less um
the the
thing where in a perfect world M every
property owner would pay their bill in
the time that they're supposed to pay it
and so one payment could be made to the
state unfortunately that's not reality
and so it would likely mean towns might
have to make multiple payments right
because they're not going to or they
would have to front the money for the
difference um so I think the system
would need to be flexible that there
might we might need to be able to
receive multiple payments yeah but every
town has very large you know
balance um accounts right they can
smooth this sort of thing out yeah
representative there's a lot of towns
that only collect twice a year some four
times a year so that would might be fine
complicate that as well right it right
and if their tax
rate is set in the fall before those
December bills that's fine but we every
year there are towns who for a variety
of reasons don't have a tax rate until
we set our last tax rate last week we so
that
municipality has not been collecting any
money from a cent or the money that they
would have collected say in January the
bills hadn't even gone out so we do have
towns that run into a bit of a cash flow
problem and need to explore options like
a tax anticipation note or other
financing to make sure that they they
can keep the lights on and the doors
open um and pay their bills so is the
swept rate like one a quar per or
something I mean a dollar and a quarter
per thousand something like that
something close to that I don't have the
I can picture the warrant but I can't
see the amount in my in my mind and when
was 363 million set I believe that was
in the original um in the original bill
it was D the original enabling
legislation it was dropped to
263 um two budgets ago for one year
correct and now back we talking about 20
years or more is yeah probably close to
you all right there might be a little
inflation since then all right
representative evil and then
representative Le thank you just back on
the low and moderate income uh thing I I
wonder because towns have the ability to
Abate property taxes based on lowincome
considerations I wonder if this is just
a
parallel authorization for the state
because swept is a state property tax
and so you want to be able to give the
lower income folks that
option yes and no it's not a full
abatement it'll be a
reimbursement um so it may not cover the
full amount um and they do need to pay
it so if they can't pay it up front
they're not going to be eligible for
this where an abatement would allow them
to just not make a payment so this is
more like a reimbursement but it may not
be for the full amount depending on the
property owner in the town kind of a
parallel a similar idea it's a way to
support those low and moderate incomes
um those with low and modate income had
I've had
constituents um to protect this
situation and with property taxes
escalating the way they are they really
do depend on this and I think you guys
have simplified the process in a way
we've try they're really thankful for
the funding good they we we try to make
it as simple as possible they can use a
paper form they can use our online forms
they can come into the office and we can
help them with it we also will now this
year have the ability um for them to
check the status of their
claim um and so we do we work with AARP
and other organizations like that that
to make sure that folks are aware of
this and can get it filed if they need
to do you know the count of the number
of people and and what does it cost your
agency is there full-time employees
involved this is handled by our taxpayer
services division it's a pretty short
season um they the claims cannot be
filed before May 1st um and so right
when we come off the tales of of April
15th the same employees can move right
into doing this there were five
811 claims last year and that makes up
that 1.1
million and any given claim isn't that
huge right they're they're they're
rather small and and the income levels
are quite low right it as you mentioned
it's a pretty simple form um we make
sure that it is filled out properly and
the documents are attached um the filing
period is May 1st to June 30 how however
um we can accept them as late as
November 1st so long as there's some
reason why there was a delay in the in
the filing and so we're pretty generous
with that um sometimes they haven't
filed their income tax their federal
income tax return which needs to be
included um there might be other reasons
but it's pretty short season and then it
it will Trail into the fall a little bit
so it's averaging like $240 each that's
roughly okay yep in my mind it's 250
represent
LE thank you Mr chairman and as always
commissioner we've got a very good uh
breakdown and we're lucky to have you I
do have a one question dealing with the
numbers U as far as the number of people
that you're unfund you're not
eliminating any of those positions just
unfunded nope they're just unfunded um
they're not abolished and again that
provision in the governor's trailer bill
um would allow us to potentially fill
some of those unfunded positions if we
can make it work um in terms of the
numbers so if there's the availability
in the budget and we can make the
numbers work we will um obviously over
the course of a bium we will have
retirements we will have people that
that leave and I fully intend to
evaluate every one of those vacancies
and determine do I need to fill that
exact position or should I look to one
of the Auditors that would generate
money or do we need support in another
area because as the chair mentioned
we're in a a time of change with the
interest in dividends tax going away and
the revenue information management
system with rims being fully operational
we are on the current version um we're
kind of cruising we're it's it's it's
paying off and so um that ability to
reflect on each vacancy as it happens
and make an educated decision about what
what we should do with that money um
that flexibility is tremendously helpful
so followup Mr chairman thank you so now
I have a question where you get paid the
big bucks for uh Revenue projections now
obviously you just mentioned interest in
dividends which is like 184 million from
the last full collection year business
taxes are down about 110 million so far
tobacco's down about 20 million how
confident are you in the figures that
we've been provided by the governor as
far as these Revenue numbers because the
trend especially business taxes is
continually going down going down sure
so the governor's Revenue estimates are
in the range of numbers that I'm
comfortable with um they are at the
higher end of the range um but for
business taxes for instance the numbers
I believe assume somewhere between a 5
to 8% year-over-year growth um business
taxes can fluctuate quite a bit and that
is difficult being our largest revenue
Source um but when you take out a nom
IES of significant increases or
significant
decreases 5 to 8% um year-over-year is
is a common you know non-anomalous
change in business taxes the reason why
I believe they're going down at the
moment um is because we are coming off
of a
period of time for businesses where
there were tremendous growth in
corporate profits there was a tremendous
amount of money in the economy from Co
relief
um and like I said business profits were
just growing many businesses especially
if they're publicly traded don't ever
want to be caught short with the amount
of money that they've paid in taxes they
don't want to report to their
shareholders that they had an unknown
large year-end tax bill so what we've
seen I believe is a lot of businesses
paying to the states and the federal
government a lot of money in estimated
payments because they didn't want to be
caught short and estimates are our
largest source of Revenue now as the
economy is kind of stabilizing we're not
in this period of tremendous growth
we're not in a downturn but we're not in
this period of tremendous growth
taxpayers are taking a step back and
saying okay I've overpaid my estimates
now two or three years in a row I'm
going to rightsize those estimated
payments so that's what I think we're
seeing we're still seeing the underlying
liability of the businesses grow from
year to year they're just rightsizing
their estimated payments and so that's
why we're seeing the reduction in
Revenue we saw this also with the tax
cut and jobs act back in
2017 many businesses knew that they were
going to face an increased tax bill at
the federal level and they weren't sure
what was going to happen at the state
level so they paid us excess amounts in
estimates and then right sized it the
next year so we're in a right sizing
mode if if that makes sense but I've
seen a lot of the increase in your
refunds which seem to be accelerating so
the increase in refunds um a large
portion of that is due to the credit
carryover cap that the legislature and
the governor put in place so businesses
can no longer carry forward from one
year to the next more than 500% of their
liability so if your liability in 24 is
$100 you can't have a credit carryover
in excess of 500
so we've been forced to
refund money back to taxpayers which has
caused the increase in refunds so just
one final comment I I miss
representative
major because Mr uh representative The
Honorable representative major uh was
probably would come in at 2% versus 5 to
8% the and I think of him often with the
credit carryovers that was a significant
concern of his um because the credit
carryover amount seemed to be kind of
ballooning year-over-year and he did
want he felt like that was a significant
liability to the state and that we
needed to do something about it so you
haven't talked to him in consultation I
have not all right representive gri um
I'm glad uh representative leechman
asked the last question because that was
my question but I'd like to know how
much how many um millions of dollars
approximately did we we return and re in
overpayments and due to the legislation
that we passed I will get you that
number I have it on a piece of paper I
believe I don't want to misspeak so I
will get you that information I have it
broken out because taxpayers do a number
of things um some request a refund and
they're not at the cap amount but
they've just chosen to take the money
back rather than leaving it on account
some taxpayers request a refund only to
that 500% cap and some go beyond the 500
but not the full amount so I have a
breakdown for you and I'm happy to
provide that to Jack to share with the
committee it seems bizarre to me that
someone would want to leave that much
money with the state I mean I'll be
honest with you when you it surprises me
too um when you look at some of these
very large multinational corporations
and you look at their apportionment to
New Hampshire so what por of their pie
is going to come to New
Hampshire you know sometimes it's less
than 1% but it's millions of dollars for
us and so I just think when they've got
the federal government large states like
New York and California I think to some
extent maybe they're not always paying
attention and they might not realize be
out of sight out of mind out of mind I
see
okay yeah representative you thank you
um so you you pretty much answered this
question about the decrease in what you
know the right sizing issue but you
remember um we switched for business
taxes purposes from taxing on personnel
and property to single sales factor and
I wondered if it's within your ability
to quantify the effect of that yep we
have that as well and I'm happy to send
that that can fluctuate from time to
time um but I can send you what the
impact of single sales Factor versus the
three- weighted double um sales Factor
meant I have um we produced that report
at the end of every month so I'm happy
to share that can you uh give a little
preview has it helped or it has helped
or it has helped great it has helped um
and that you know U theoretically makes
sense given this time of economic
growth um focusing solely the
apportionment solely on sales when
economy is doing really well it it would
make sense that it has been beneficial
so that kind of tracks with the theory
it's very so unlike the other method
it's pretty um economy related so if we
were in a recession it could push it
down right the I would say sales when
you're talking about payroll property
and sales sales is the most vital of
those factors right that can your sales
can change very quickly just based on
the wind out in the economy right
consumers you know if you're in retail
consumers can get skittish very quickly
um payroll you're more businesses are
more in charge of that presumably they
take any layoffs or significant
decreases or changes to their payroll
that is something that doesn't always
happen overnight it tends to be a longer
process and same with property buying or
selling a property changing the amount
of property that a business owns is
again something that is not going to
change Like the Wind so the payroll and
property factors tend to be a bit more
stable um but at least at this point
single sales Factor has has been um
Revenue positive for us thank you um the
governor's budget includes uh money from
slot machines is that a vect you at all
or is that all lottery that's all
lottery okay and I have a feeling I
asked this question two years ago but
I'll ask it again anyway Which tax is um
the most expensive to collect in terms
of cost for for income you don't
remember my answer I
don't the interest and dividends the
interest and dividends tax that's gone
so what's the next one oh there aren't
left the the reason for the interest in
dividends tax is you you asked a great
question about the number of taxpayers
and how the number of taxpayers is very
similar to number of business taxpayers
business taxes bring over you know
billion dollars a year interest in
dividends while meaning full at 184
million is much less than that um with
interest in dividends tax we receive a
lot of um returns for you know $100 $200
as I mentioned especially in the past
year where a lot of folks were caught
not realizing that they they had a
filing obligation but interest rates
were high and they earned some interest
income that that put them over the
threshold that they hadn't seen that
level of interest inome in years so
okay after interest in dividends
[Music]
um it would it would be hard because um
the tobacco tax while it impacts
everyone that consumes tobacco or
nicotine products it's collected at the
wholesale level um and so our universe
that we're dealing with there is smaller
the real estate transfer tax is
collected by the counties um the meals
and rentals tax is collected by The
Operators that's probably in the next
largest
volume in terms of returns excluding
because it's monthly but again it's
largely automated through the system um
probably Statewide would be uh toll
boost I would guess yeah but that's not
involving you right right okay thank you
very much commissioner staff we're
keeping the Secretary of State waiting
so all right this excellent presentation
just Charlie AR Department right yes we
haven't seen it yet yeah he came they
came spoke but that was just the
preliminary right we haven't had the
fold yeah that's right
yeah I marked preliminary with a DOT I
understand no he's talking with him all
right
so welcome secretary
be yeah all right so now we are going to
be on page uh 112 through 126 maybe
we'll start on 126
and3
yeah3 yeah oh this is an error by the
way Jack in the um in the index it says
113 but it's actually
[Laughter]
112 So I I check it last night cuz I was
I saying why are we starting in the
middle anyways so this budget
um yeah so so uh there's there's a four
more employees and a significant
increase in general funds and a
significant decrease in other funds so
it looks
interesting
[Music]
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State um before I get
started representative wer held up the
uh pocket
Constitution that that uh you know this
this committee had a lot to do with I
actually have some one of my staff
members coming across the street with uh
copies for each of you but we waited
until after the Constitutional
question uh was disposed of on the on
the last ballot and then we were able to
print them so we have a generous Supply
if you have any that you want to give to
your constituents or if your
constituents want to come and pick them
up they they are now available and I
think they came out
great so uh the budget that is before
you is the one that's proposed by the
governor uh we made the uh suggested
cuts that uh she proposed um and there
are four positions that are requested in
the bud three of those are
replacing uh existing temporary
positions that are currently filled uh
at the present
time uh so those positions will actually
increase the general fund uh component
there but under the temporary um I think
they drop off and then uh I have a uh an
assistant secretary position that is
currently filled with an individual that
is working on uh voter Outreach and
Civics uh
education uh the proposal is to make
position and that is a summary of the
four positions that are in the
budget oh but it's currently an
unclassified position yes so shouldn't
that go from 16 to
uh I don't think we're eliminating the
unclassified position so we're just
we're creating oh for this particular
project yes but you'll still have an
assistant
secretary yeah okay I get it um I think
that you received a copy of the vacant
positions um that we currently Have I
None of those are funded however with
General
funds
[Music]
um you know I think that um you know
maybe for the benefit of the newer
members on the
committee uh the Secretary of State's
office raises a lot of Revenue
um uh in our Securities division all of
the fees that are paid by broker dealer
registrations are uh go directly to the
general fund and that amounts to about
$44
million Securities operates on the fine
money that they collect uh they're able
to carry over I think it's
750,000 from one by anym to the next
just to meet payroll but then once the
fines are collected they continue and
any additional funds there laps to the
general
fund uh same thing with corporations
division uh that
um
all uh Corporation
registrations and other types of
registrations other than LLC go directly
to the general fund corporations runs
off of the LLC Revenue that is collected
and then uh at the end of each year we
lapse uh I think it's at least $5
million back uh to the general
fund you said there's 44 million of of
uh Securities fines per year no not
fines there's there's there's $44
million of Securities Revenue okay which
is registrations for broker
dealers um financial instruments that
are being offered in New Hampshire have
to pay a registration fee all of that
money goes directly to the general fund
and some are
fines no no okay the fine money that is
collected through enforcement actions is
retained by the Secretary of State's
office to pay the expenses of operating
Securities and then any money that is
left over uh oh so there's a dedicated
fund for that and if it's greater than x
it lapses I understand okay now um when
were the fees involved in those two
things the Securities and corporate
registrations when were those
set when were they created when were the
last change when when they it's been it
has been a long time I I do you know I
don't know when they were raised last
you mean the filing fees themselves yeah
the registration fees yeah yeah I mean X
dollar per LLC we have not raised any
any fees for many years um it's been
over 10 any at least yeah could you find
out in detail yeah whatever the history
is of these fees right and I assume
they're set in statute I'm sorry I
didn't your they're in statute yes these
fees yeah
yeah thank
you all right do you want to start
should we go back to the beginning and
yep wherever you want to go we're happy
to answer questions let's start on page
okay all right
[Music]
so
um so here we
got uh so this is all general fund but
you said no nobody's vacant here
the the the positions on page 12
are the that's the administrative office
basically it's my salary the deputy
salary the senior Deputy salary and then
uh some of the uh key office staff are
also unclassified those are positions
that you would expect would change when
there's a turnover in uh Secretary of
State
Administration is were some of these un
unfilled for part of the year in 2024 or
something like that I am not aware of
any that were unfilled I'm just asking
because like line 12 for example is
going up by by $100,000 compared to to
2024 so I don't think you're getting
that kind of a raise right so that would
be
nice
um the senior deputy is uh didn't work
probably as many hours in that year and
then they're paid by the day yeah um
the so the
um of course I'm working full-time and
Aaron Hennessy is working full-time
Patty Lovejoy was in a position called
the senior Deputy position which is a
statutory position that is authorized to
work up to 90 days a year I I don't
think think she uh met I don't think she
came close to the 90 days so there would
have been some uh uh but it's budgeted
for 90 days going for right it's it's
budgeted for the full amount even
250,000 for 90 days that can't be
right
no we'll we'll dig dig deeper into that
thank you I'm sure there's an
explanation for yeah because if if some
of those could be reduced a little that
would help okay
and and similarly um I guess benefits is
also going up by 100,000 so so it feels
like there's more full-time work I guess
for some
reason um okay or is that yeah okay all
right let's go on other anybody else
other questions on this page um let's go
so who is this new
position
right that's the C's
position right on on
uh class 10 on page 115 would be the the
position changing the uh
assistant oh doing Civics to the
classified position what do you mean by
Civics the voter education voter and
Outreach can
you can you tell me more about
that we've spent a lot of time over the
years uh in the
elections um meeting the mandates of the
help America vote act which includes
also training election officials but
what we have seen over the last probably
10 years is a a uh a decline in the
confidence that voters have an election
a lot of it is their understanding of
the process and uh we really have not
focused at all on communicating with the
voters in the state and uh I believe
that is a critical component of the
health of our election system to have
programs where we do just that
especially in light of a lot of the
election Law changes that have taken
place uh more recently so that's the
need for that position so so how would
that so what what we're doing is uh we
are reaching out to a wide range of
voter
constituencies some of them are students
uh veterans groups minority groups
senior groups disabilities groups and
trying to speak speak to them as groups
and we're doing a couple of things
educating them on voting processes uh
which is very important but also as part
of that we're trying to encourage them
to become actually engaged in the
process and think about volunteering as
pole workers uh and helping run the
elections locally because I mean we're
struggling to get people to do those
jobs and so we're just trying to
invigorate that whole that whole process
I see so um getting people to sign up
for the um those positions to run for
those positions those sixe what are they
called ballot supervisor supervisor the
checklist yeah so we're not we're not
trying to get people to run for offices
I mean hopefully you know maybe by
talking to them they might become
motivated to do that but we are asking
people to volunteer just you know help
help work as a ballot Clerk or you know
there many jobs to do in a polling place
on Election Day right
okay okay good so um
page
okay corporate
Administration
so um there's a lot of big changes on
this page um current
expenses you actually spent
275 what is that is that printing
ballots or something is no no no no so
corporations division is
the probably the largest division that
we have in terms of
employees and workload um oh yes you're
getting two more employees here I'm
sorry there are two more employees being
added okay those two those are the
conversions that that I was talking
about
earlier
um we have been working on a major
overhaul of the
uh Software System and
database uh in
corporations if you recall four years
ago uh you know we were having real
serious problems with people being able
to use the system we had a vendor who
was
um
U incompetent um they they were not uh
they were not responsive to the issues
and the concerns concerns that we had so
we had to bring somebody in stabilize
the system and now we're well on our way
to uh having a system that is operating
uh without without issues and so you
know the complaints that you may have
been getting as legislators four years
ago simply are not happening now the um
most of the
transactions of people registering their
business it's annual return season right
now uh are being done online and so that
we have very little foot traffic now
that's coming into the office and
um um yeah so with less foot traffic
shouldn't there be fewer employees
you're adding two we're we're converting
the positions we're not we're not adding
there people are already there or there
temp there were temps is that what
you're saying yeah the the nature of the
jobs are changing from um what used to
be paper clerks just people filing
papers and applications to people that
need to be able to offer uh help with
the computer system if somebody has a
question about online how to take care
of something so um that was part of a
conversion that we did a few years ago
we came and asked the committee if you
know we could upgrade some of the
positions and as part of that we did uh
eliminate some positions uh in
corporations uh as
well um am I missing anything no no okay
and you finished buying your software
and your Hardware it looks like yeah I
mean but that is an ongoing you know
there will be ongoing expenses because
any database needs to be sure maintained
and so you know we have contracts with
vendors for that purpose but the bulk of
it is gone away okay what is Grants
nonfederal
that's the UCC money
okay go go go and explain it yeah
um um Uniform Commercial Code which are
leans that are filed um historically
they had to file with the town and with
the state um quite a few probably at
least 10 years ago now the law they
changed the law and now they only file
with the state but we give back to the
towns their portion of the fee so once
at the end of the year when all the
filings have been tabulated um the towns
are given this money back um for their
portion of the filings and that's that
line that's where we take the money from
and give it to the towns all right
um Jack why don't we find out where that
is in the rsas I probably know but okay
so
page 119
okay so people used to file with
towns they got money they don't anymore
so we give them money we not doing we
basically collect it on behalf of the
towns and give it back to them rather
than the people have to be filing in two
separate places saying yeah yeah yeah do
you tell them who filed and all that uh
the well the the records can't be
searched it's a public record it's a
public record okay all right good any
other so let's go on
um page
120 oh what is private local
funds on page 120 so
this well the drop was because they they
bought all their
software right and they so the main P
what is what is private local funds what
mean that's that's the um revenue from
um the llc's that is used to run the
division and I don't know why it's
titled that way we don't make those
titles it comes to us from
administrative Services
okay all right but that's basically
that's basically the charged to to
companies for registering yeah
dropped from 10 to five that's that is
the estimate as the year goes on on that
will adjust it's not it's Mo it very
most likely won't come in at five it's
going to come in like at 10 but it's
it's see you know it's it's an ongoing
they update it as go that yes it's an
expense that's the budgeted expense
however it's run off the fees so
depending how many fees are collected
depends on how much you have to run the
division is there a dedicated fund
involved
it's rest restricted unrestricted
Revenue I always get those backwards
it's a restricted Revenue Source gotcha
yeah
okay all
right yeah so it's the expense right
there was an this is expense this is not
right that's the expense
right yeah yeah but that's because
anyway any I get it you get it okay uh
let's go on to where we on page 120
um
so in the in the
archive um was there vacant positions
in um 2024 is that why there's such a
smaller number
there I believe we had one vacant
position in
2024 okay but one since all 10 are now
there it's yes all positions now yes
they're all we don't have any vacant
positions currently in the archives okay
and is there really work for 10
people and more and more
okay so explain what what is the
um The Archives has you know
responsibilities in addition
to you know maintaining and and uh and
protecting the collections that are up
there we have um we have a couple of
Staff people that are constantly uh
digitizing Records part of that are
legislative records and you know I think
there's if you get on the legislative
website there's an option for you know
looking at the history of whole bills
well you know it those staff people are
um working to bring those digitized
records forward but they're also going
backward and so there is a a fairly
large window of years now where you know
the historical data is available and
then in addition to that uh we have
staff that are managing agency records
uh there's over 100,000 boxes of Records
in that facility they are they are in a
status that is between the active use of
an agency and and when they can be
destroyed according to a specific
retention schedule that
exists there is there are a lot of
occasions where an agency needs to
access some of the files in those boxes
and so we manage all of that if if an
agency makes a request for people to go
retrieve the files
pull them deliver them to the agency
pick them up when they're done bring
them back refile and then part of that
process is when the retention schedule
arrives uh for Destruction they confirm
with the agency that it is okay to
destroy those records and then that
process takes place and
um uh and we make more room obviously in
the stacks for more boxes we just
upgraded the um inventory computerized
inventory system up there and so now
we've got a major project going on where
we are going through all of the boxes in
the archives and doing a reinvent just
to make sure you know we know where
everything is and and that the past
retention schedules have been properly
met representative wer are you also
responsible for cataloging all these TV
things that are being made in every
every committee that you know somebody
could say oh we had this bill three
other times I want to see all the all
the recordings of of the discussion on
that bill is that something you have to
be responsible for I don't believe we're
responsible for that in the in the short
term but over time we take the those
records uh in the
archives um we we have created a state
of-the-art digitization center up there
and so you know we're doing a lot more
with with digital records uh helping
smaller agencies digitize their records
as well I've been impressed when
somebody say oh I saw that from two
years ago and I went online and pulled
it up wow
impressive yeah represent of you yeah
just just a comment I remember talking
about this digitization effort during
capital budget discussions and I
remember once we visited Department of
justice and it was like the quarter was
this wide with boxes stacked as far as
the eye could see and not we were so
behind on the digitization so I know you
you need what you have budgeted here
from visualizing
it there seems to be
no no um budget for equipment wouldn't
you wouldn't you generally need more
disc drives or more you know storage
electronic storage
equipment every year well I I we we we
pick it up as we need it you know it it
um we're in pretty good shape at the
moment so there is no re or is that
current expense
maybe yeah okay um you have a fairly
High uh rent that you pay so is there
more than buildings more more than just
the one where I see you do the recounts
or is there other buildings too we get
we get charged pretty stiff rent for the
use of that building that's just that's
it that building I see because it
charged for the NX as well this is
400,000 Char for the annex as well yeah
oh the annex yeah yeah the our
corporation's division is housed in the
Annex Building we get charged rent there
as well of course yeah the AR and the
archives building we get charged rent
for yeah I mean
seems Seems high but that wouldn't be
that wouldn't come under archives though
right plant and property would be
somewhere else right that the the annex
would be for corporations and and
securities but yeah we get charged
pretty hefty rent for the archives
building yeah it looks like 400,000 a
year yeah okay yeah we we get told what
to pay input in the budget we that's
determined by administrative Services
okay all right well maybe we'll ask him
about that
um so is this the one
[Music]
where you converted some Consultants to
that or maybe these Consultants were
with the new computer system so
um
Securities engages in a lot of
enforcement actions that's how they
collect Their fines and they do have to
reach out to all outside consultants and
experts for the cases that they bring in
addition to that uh the secretary of
state is responsible
for oversight of the pulled risk
organizations under RSA
5B and uh we have been engaged in some
actions with those
organizations
um they uh they challenge us a lot in
court and you know that has been very
manage okay why is current expense high
in 2024 and not afterward is that also
connected to the computer system or
something
Consultants uh some some of that would
could current expense could be like um
not like software but other components
um related to technology gotcha
okay all
right
so this one um looks like you're losing
a Federal grant right um because the
general fund component is doubling over
27 and the federal grants down 130 or so
125 we have had a con contractual
arrangements with the federal
CDC to share uh information that is
collected through the vital records
process it's in aggregate form you know
there's no personal identifiers that
have gone along with that um part of
that is uh birth information information
related to uh the mother uh and the
parents um there has been some action by
the legislature recently to pull back on
providing that data and if we don't
provide the data that you know that the
federal government is looking for then
the expectation is they they're not
going to uh pay us pay us for
it
okay all right and you're and yet you're
adding a
person it's a conversion again it's
that's a
conversion conversion I will tell you
that the um division of Vital Records
came to the Secretary of State's office
in the early 2000s probably around
2003 2004 so they've been a part of of
the Department of State for at least 20
years
now um part of the agreement for taking
Bal Records Was
reducing the cost and managing the um
the agency fund funds for the intended
purpose there is a dedicated fund that
goes with Vital Records called the vital
fund and those
funds are to be dedicated to improve the
collection uh of the data and the
administration of the records primarily
with the city and town clerks who are
the agents for the state and you know
and are responsible for a lot of that
information
and so uh we've been successful in doing
that we' we've reduced the number of
employee employees from when they first
came over we've kept the cost down and
uh we maintain a healthy balance uh in
the fund healthy means right now I think
it's
uh I think it's around $3
million but we use that to uh create the
modules for like bird death marriage
data um and the staff at work at vital
records are kind of dedicated to each of
those areas even though we do cross Trin
so um a lot of that money is used for uh
software upgrades and Hardware that is
used at the local level by the uh Town
clerks yeah because I don't see you said
it's conversion but I don't see any
number going down right so you would
think temps would go down or something
right oh because it's um that that
conversion is the position the the
individual that's been um working on
that is currently housed in corporate in
the corporate budget we're sending it
over um so the temp in corporate went
down um you just don't see it in the
vital records piece I see now Vital
Records Improvement says that it gets
its money from
um revolving
funds so what are
those so whenever a
um whenever a person requests a vital
record let's say they show up at the at
The Archives they pay a fee Bal records
and they want a birth certificate or a
death certificate there are fees that
are atted
with that and uh a portion of those fees
are diverted to the V record Improvement
fund to the extent that the clerks
collect those fees in their offices they
also retain a portion of the fee for
Town use gotcha so make a add that to
your list of other fees right to to give
it to us in terms of when they were last
changed and and what how much they are
and I guess where they are in statute
okay good
so
um
that's so what's the difference between
a vital records Improvement employee and
a vital records Bureau
employee a vital records Improvement
employee is paid for out of the vital
records Improvement fund and those
individuals primarily are
dealing with data um that is collected
as a result of of the fund the other is
just employees that are paid for with a
combination of general fund and and
federal money is one more the inputs and
or
um well the the the ones that are funded
by the Improvement fund or data input
the others are are more focused on the
activity that would take place whether
there was a fund or not those are the
ones that are responsible for all of the
data related to births let's say and
marriages okay all right all right that
questions yes representative
wiing I don't know if call has been
recognized she's got how many years of
service uh
40 just 40 I thought it went over 40 oh
well next month it'll be 40 month next
month 40 yeah longest serving employee I
I remember so no well thank you for that
we have in Dees the longest serving
employee ah oh renie renie renie p
show me he's almost 50 I think he's
getting close to 50 yeah so you have to
to okay other questions any other points
representive gr thank
you um my question I guess is you you
collect fees on a number of things that
you do and those fees find their way to
mostly mostly yes so what we didn't talk
about was in the administrative office
um citizens of New Hampshire come in
there for certain things whether it's to
get an AOS steel for something
overseas um we used to issue things like
Hawker um Hawkers licenses Hawkers and
peders license we don't do that anymore
but um they're they're just
miscellaneous fees applications for
notary public and justices of the piece
and so we collect those
fees and they usually find their they
not usually they do find their way to
the general fund but there are for
example notaries and justices of the
peace uh we collect the fees we are
allowed to
retain I think it's $100,000 anything
over that laps is that allows us to pay
for the staff person that administers
that and also produce the the manuals to
go along with what's needed for the
position and so um you know we we manage
that and then we have a recount
administration fee account monies that
are collected when the candidate wants a
recount or whatever deposited in that
fund I know if that's lapsing or it's
non- lapsing um but those monies help
pay for the cost of the rec of you know
getting people to help conduct a recount
it's not a large amount of money it's so
that gets to my question and I that I
want to ask and that is um what are the
total fees collected by the state
up uh let us get that number together
for you you know including the money
that automatically goes to the general
okay representative W yeah our thoughts
on that some of these fees have been
unchanged for 15 20 years in the
meantime we're struggling to balance a
budget and some of these fees could help
help if we increase the amount of money
without you know a lot of grief on the
people because they pay them like once
in a lifetime or something and uh you
know and still it might lessen the
amount of General funds to operate that
agency if if we had fees that help
balance it so what we'll do is probably
a major adjustment on fees because some
of them haven't been adjusted in 15 20
years
so yeah or 50 anyway I think it's
important we know one that's a policy
decision yeah all right any other
questions no well obviously the labor
department is is not very busy because
the commissioner is here 20 minutes
ahead of time so even be on time yeah
all right well thank you very much uh Mr
secretary all right so we'll we'll be in
3:15
e
it yeah I don't know it's also 26 it's
also socialists
that's the new
trigger that's the new trigger word over
there it's socialist
okay what about
all right bipartisan initiative right
all right let's settle down here all
right we're having too much fun we're
having too much fun it's the last one of
the day and we will Rec recognize um
commissioner Maryfield of the Department
of Labor welcome sir and we are on page
299 299 to
304 and I have like three questions only
so you know we're not going to be here
long all
right so page
[Music]
okay all right so why don't we start at
page 304 and ask the hard question
which
is I wanted to offer Mr chairman I mean
I could I could talk a little bit about
our operations and then talk about
significant changes in the budget or
yeah let's just let go let's go right to
the heart of it which is significant
changes in the budget okay you want two
and a half M oh you have a handout yeah
oh I didn't see that here it is okay
excellent why do you want 2 and a half
million
more 2 and a half million more thought I
was L I know there's no General funds
but still it's somebody's funds right I
mean sure uh so uh what I guess I'd like
to to do to start is to discuss the the
two types of Revenue that support the
activities of the department yeah let's
get into the detail so so we are we are
funded 100% by agency income um however
that comes from two different uh
distinct sources the administration fund
and the restricted fund and the
administration fund is is described in
the workers comp law and it comes from a
prata assessment of the budget that you
approve as legislature uh it's assessed
on all the insurance carriers based on
the claims that they paid in the prior
year um and so that represents actually
87% of our budget request is build to
the insurance carriers who write workers
comp in the state of New Hampshire so
that's as opposed to on premiums correct
it's it's it's based on claims paid
interesting okay yeah um now the
restricted fund on the other hand is
described in RSA
273 and it comes from the sum of all of
the other fees fines certificates
licenses every other kind of Revenue
that we produce at the labor department
that goes into the restricted fund which
supports any of our activities not
associated with workers comp and then
the balance of that fund after we pay
our expenses each year goes back to the
general fund so I'm I'm happy to report
that our four best years in history were
the last four years um we've ex
historically the Department's turned
over uh between 1 and 1 and A5 million
and in the last last four years we've
turned over either two or three million
depending on you know how much how much
we've
collected okay so you're saying after
these expenses of uh 1. something
million You' what's left has gone to the
general fund of of two to three million
correct I understand y okay very good um
so uh in preparing our budget uh
governor sununu's office provided us
with an overall efficiency Target of
just over 12 million uh uh we we met
that Target and then uh second year of
the budget uh he allowed us to increase
for certain position costs and we we
beat that Target as well in preparing
the expense budget um Governor aot uh
made only modest adjustments uh she
eliminated uh uh roughly 20,00 ,000 in
priority needs which actually we did not
request it was agencies that we transfer
money to that requested that $20,000 so
those were eliminated and also there
were some um not uncommonly in the
governor's phase of the budget there are
adjustments made to employee benefits
usually a reduction and that's what
happened in this case too so very modest
um changes uh in Governor aot's budget
uh so in 26 and 27 we have requested no
new positions that leaves us at the 87
uh full-time authorized positions as
supported in the prior B uh bium that
followed uh the abolition of eight
positions in the prior bium and uh we
did have one position added in the most
recent version of House Bill 2 uh the
Senate added a program and a position uh
for us so so we we ended up with 87
full-time authorized positions uh coming
into this ban into this biannual budget
any vacant I'm sorry vacant on yes we
have vacancies okay um I didn't count
but SE several are are being recruited
and SE several actually been hired I
think three yeah have been hired in the
last few days in fact um oh so you're
not subject to the the hiring for we are
but we have way waivers I see we have
waivers okay
um so uh notable changes in our
efficiency request include a slight
increase in class 17 special payments
which we use to fund uh retirement or
termination payouts uh we had
significant reductions in our transfers
to doit and general Services uh an
increase in equipment in year one for
the purchase of a new truck to transport
uh to transport our elevator testing
weights uh you can imagine uh in when
you're testing a new elevator the
weights I believe total something like
2,500 lb and we're carrying them around
in these little sedans that our labor
inspectors use so it's uh it's bruising
anyway and we we think we'd be better
off to dedicate a an appropriate vehicle
for that um
service huh one way
uh I'm not sure I know I know the total
because they have to get up to 2500
pounds I think to to do the full test
that's a lot ofs correct in and out of
the building all the time yeah so um
let's
see oh and uh testing weights and U we
also had a significant increase you'll
notice in our um Statewide cost
allocation plan fund our indirect cost
um we have seen that grow in the last
three years by about $100,000 a year um
so we're health and commissioner Arling
house with his
needs um let's see we also significantly
reduced the budget for part-time
temporary staffing um but increased the
uh the budget for our administratively
attached boards who are paid um on a per
DM rate for for their hearings that they
hold in our building um and there's a
significant increase in year one in our
class 103 operational contracts line and
that's because I have I have some
building needs that I I think are going
to have to be met by local funding in
instead of admin administrative services
so so we asked for an increase there and
that that really concludes what what I
had to say about significant changes and
offer to take any questions all right
well let's get back to why is fiscal
year 24 so different than fiscal year
25 so that's we UND spent by probably $2
million yeah yeah can't you do that
again
or I hesitate to say with
so does that it doesn't help you however
um to to any significant degree I see
um so in what sense
um we have workers comp all throughout
the state budget right
so does it
somehow some of that make its way back
to you or no oh well I shouldn't say
that I guess it does yeah because we
very small probably right it has to do
with the ratio of number of state
employees compared to all employees or
something that St the state's carrier
would get a share of our budget they
would have to pay a share of our budget
I
see um and did you underspend the budget
mainly because of these vacant positions
is that um 2024 pretty Frugal I think
we're conservative yeah and it's
historically the labor department has
undp underspent the budget by a good
20% Which becomes lapses is well well
not really right the not really because
the again 87% of the budget is this
Administration fund that is uh built out
to the insurance carriers but then I am
obligated what whatever is left over in
that fund I'm obligated to take out of
the next year
so the carriers get that back if I don't
spend it the carriers get it
back oh so it's so if we wanted somehow
more money it has to come from the
restricted fund right which is a very
small actually a very small portion of
what we do yeah I see okay and are any
of the the fees and fines in the
restricted
fund listed in statute or they oh they
are yeah okay yeah all of them in one
way or another they are yeah yeah so so
like the Civil penalties that we impose
say as the result of a wage an hour
inspection those civil penalties are
capped at $2,500 per violation by
Statute um but we you know we have a
formula depending on you know whether
it's a repeat customer the severity of
the infraction so forth to calculate
what the Civil penalty should be um but
we're capped at $2500 it's it's rare
that we actually go to the full
$2,500 what do you mean $25 an hour I'm
sorry did you say $25 an hour no 20
$2500 per violation per violation $2,500
per violation oh I see violation that's
the maximum that the Labor Commissioner
can impose I gotcha but but you have
some
some internal is this in
rules what you do no it's just
flexibility we we have a rubric for you
know so that we treat everyone the same
way
um have have we ever visited before is
you know is this a frequent flyer uh so
so on and so forth what's the severity
did they not pay wages or is this just a
paperwork error you know
um so so that determines how severe a
penalty will
impose okay so tell me where in statute
that is not now
11a that's where the maximum civil
penalty language is but throughout our
statute the you know the elevators and
boiler certificates all of that is set
in statute as well
has it own schematic right workers comp
uh for example the largest revenue that
we have coming out of workers comp are
uh penalties that we impose on the
carriers for late
reporting uh we are we are allowed to
charge them or find them as much as $50
a day uh our current rubric we're we're
charging them $112 a
period I see and and that's just your
own decision
yes because the statute says $50 up to
$50 up to up to right I got it all right
so we might like you to charge a little
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah okay I get it
but there's no but it's not statute
currently um and many do Char come late
report late on this kind of thing yeah
yeah and and if I could describe I mean
the our interest in that is we we need
to know if for example an employer has
allowed their workers comp policy to
lapse because now we then have workers
out there who are unprotected from
workplace injuries so we're going to
take some kind of action when we know
you know that workers are
uncovered uh and if the carrier is
delinquent and reporting that condition
to us people could be could be working
you know I see for a longer period of
time uncovered yeah yeah right so it is
important it is important it's important
for us to know okay yeah and $12 a day
doesn't sound like much right it's our
number one Revenue got is the is the
penalties on
carriers apart from apart from that
administration of
course got you representative wer as I
recall workers comp is a major part of
of your
operations I guess you people come to
bring the claim to you when you decide
whether it's valid or not we we provide
a forum when there's a dispute between
the the injured worker uh and the
insurance carrier we we provide the
forum for deciding that and then there's
also an administratively attached board
who will hear appeals of our decisions
as well and they are they operate in our
building are these generally short term
and the person recovers or is it
sometimes permanent damage oh it can be
for sure for sure and then do they
continue to collect work as comp if if
they hav permanent damage um settlements
R yeah
there's sorry there there are um it's a
possibility if an injured worker has a
disability a work resultant disability
um in which a medical provider has
determined that they are not they're not
sufficiently released to return to work
it's conceivable that they could
continue to collect um what we would
call those cash benefits paid for by the
insurance carrier um for a long long
period of time individuals who have
partial disabilities um Can time out on
those payments those don't necessarily
last longer than uh five years and some
change 262 weeks I had one person
complain to me that he collected work as
comp for a while and in one job and went
to another job and he collected work as
comp there and he said tried to get a
third job everybody seemed to know that
he collected work as comp so is that
something that's publicly available
claim information is yeah claim
information is protected by Statute so
IND you know the the information that
the Department of Labor holds relative
to a particular person's claims uh in
the absence of a specific release from
that person isn't something we're able
to share maybe it's something they've
got to put on the job application but he
said that seemed to be the reason why he
couldn't get hired in a third job
because he collected twice sure so I
guess some people scam it thank you
represent Griffin uh thank you thank you
for taking my question uh on page five
of your handout you U talk about the
Inspection
Division they uh check establishments
for compliance with employment laws they
respond to complaints M would those be
complaints from
employees typically and what would the
nature of those complaints be wasn't
paid wasn't paid on time uh um my
12-year-old son is working 40 hours a
week um you name it the the the gamut
how about uh things like
uh uh discrimination based on age or we
we will get those kinds of complaints
but they fall with the Human Rights
Commission discrimination CLA we have
very very
limited um uh purview over
discrimination of any
right well the reason I asked is because
we're dealing with the Human Rights
Commission that just said the worst
audit we've ever seen and I I read it
and uh it's just incredible people make
complaints and then they lose their
right to go to court because they're not
dealt with for three
years and I wondered whether you guys
could take up the
slack it's it's not it's not our St
statue it's not within our purview um
until you make it our purview than gu
thank you so much for
sure okay um other questions yeah so I'm
interested in this um taxing the claims
rather than the the
premiums I'm wondering yeah I think uh
Insurance uh has an identical um
something very similar very similar
language in their um in their statute
and their their funding mechanism but
didn't didn't we hear from them that
they get money from premiums and not and
not from
claims yeah I remember reading their
statute years ago and I thought it it it
sounded like they created us at exactly
the same time because because the
language read almost exactly the same
but but it could well be that their
their formula is different so Melissa
can you compare those maybe yeah because
I I'd be interested because it's it's
and I'm just wondering you know I'm sure
you don't consciously act in one way or
another right but but it does sort of
put you on the side of the
claim receive the person who receives
the claim as opposed
to a little bit less neutral right
so the which the premium might be so I
don't know um yeah I well I don't I mean
you'll approve a budget I I hope you'll
approve a budget for the labor
department sure uh uh and then the the
only use for the claims data is to
decide how much each carrier is going to
pay so the income to me is going to be
identical regard regardless of who pays
oh I see so you take your budget and
divide and divide it up among all these
carriers based on how many claims
they're paying exactly and otherwise it
could be based on how much premiums they
charge for example yeah I I mean you
could you could find which is the way I
think I think in the back of my mind
that's what the insurance department
does okay representative Griffin see I I
see it just the opposite I by basing on
claims you're encouraging the uh
yeah then they get a l lower I I would
say though to based on the the amount of
losses that insurance carriers pay my
budget is an afterthought yeah our but
our budget is so much smaller that's
such a tiny percentage of their cost and
that's the same thing in the insurance
department they're they're one and a
half perent or something I don't know
it's very tiny
yeah okay all right other questions
representative
Lehman thanks Mr chairman I I apologize
just for the minutes it's Maryfield
right yes oh I'm sorry D didn't even say
my name you you might have but but then
I went to your website to try to find it
and I couldn't find any ref to you
whatsoever I know some of us use that as
an advertising
opport but there was something I came
across here I had a question what is
employee leas
sing such a I'll I'll let you such a
very excellent question so in New
Hampshire we have a specific statute
that's administered through the
Department of Labor that provides for
certain requirements and Licensing of
what are called employee leasing
companies or um peos uh professional
employment organizations oh so like an
employment agency type of thing or temp
temp somewhat different so a temp agency
is an employer in its own right it takes
you know it has its own employees and
then essentially contracts out or or or
Farms out those employees to work at
like a host company when we're talking
about peos or leasing companies engaging
in relationships with client companies
under the law if you're with a licensed
um organization and that licensure does
come through the department it's one of
the fees that we charge for applications
and then issuance of said license it's
creating a co-employment relationship
where both the peo and then the client
come
are responsible for certain um labor
oriented rights under under the statute
so it creates a very unique employment
scenario that is regulated through the
department thanks thanks chairman what's
an example of that um so an example
would be I believe um
ADP is paychecks paychecks are peos um
people people source is a peo and and
essentially when we you know when you
look at the statutory requirement this
peo almost operates or serves as the
centralized almost like human resources
so they're responsible for putting
together policies for the client company
administering payroll assuring that the
insurance um policies inclusive of
workers compensation are obtained are
and in place uh for what for the
employees who are under the care and
control of the client company so company
X engages in the relationship with um
ADP company X is directing the employees
might be setting the rate of pay for
those employees uh the peo is going to
make sure the grievance policies are in
place the notifications um about pay and
and hiring have gone out um that workers
comp is in place that payroll is coming
on time and is administered
appropriately so they share employment
responsibilities and each is responsible
by law um for their designated portion
in order for those peos to operate
legally in our state they do have to be
licensed they're vetted there's certain
um security requirements or or or
Securities that we want to see or that
the statute wants to see um on on file
and then they renew I want to say every
two years and then if they're in good
standing for some period of time they
period it's a very unique um
situation and is often Mis uh confused
with um with the temp agencies but temp
agencies are different okay you're
welcome is your phone making noise okay
all right thank you any other questions
no okay well we won't approve this yet
because we want to talk about fees and
stuff and and uh possibly the human
rights aspect as well so thank you very
much for coming thank you thank you
we'll talk again but probably not here
necessarily um yeah something else yes
House Bill two oh yes House Bill two is
that in your did you pack want to
yes
where oh page 57 of house B
okay we only have it in draft we don't
ahead you want me to take you through
our yes go ahead if you have it okay um
we we were alerted our first section I
think has to do with wage claim
settlements in wage W wage claim
settlement account and uh we we were
alerted by uh Bureau of accounts uh uh
at the end of last fiscal year that we
didn't have statutory authority to do
what we were doing uh and in essence
we're we're we have a holding account
for wages that are turned over to us and
we can't locate the employee so we we
hold that and it's not it's not property
of the state so we don't lapse it we
don't turn it over to the state at the
end of the fiscal year so this was just
to clarify that language so that we
could maintain those those wages for for
the employees and so we can find them do
you turn them over after 10 years of
looking or something
property abandoned property eventually
gets it yeah yeah I see okay um then uh
number two we had a special Fund in the
workers comp law uh that was a an effort
by the legislature to hold harmless when
there was an overhaul of the workers
comp statute they wanted to hold certain
Active cases harmless so that people
wouldn't wouldn't see a change in their
benefits
the the last recipient uh from that
special fund has passed away and so we
Statute what else do I
have number three insurance
carriers oh yes Danielle you're more
expert on this uh so number three um is
uh proposing to make an amendment to um
the workers compensation statute
specifically the section 43 which talks
about hearings and awards um several
years ago back in 2006 there was an
amendment to that statute that altered
the compliance time frame that insurance
carriers had to issue payment of ordered
payment of cash benefits to Injured
Workers it changed the language from um
it requiring the insurance carriers to
pay Injured Workers if ordered to do so
within 5 days of issuance of a decision
um to 30 plus 5 days um the department
and all of the participants in these
hearing processes continued for up until
very recently to operate under the
former
language um when it came to our
attention that we were not administering
it correctly um we did take steps to
make the change however that has
resulted in delay of payment to Injured
Workers who are awaiting an appeal
process um it it makes them wait longer
to get the money that's resulted in an
increase on Outreach about delayed
payment and hardship and things of that
nature so given the fact that the
participants were operating under the
former language the Department's been
operating under the former language
we're proposing to um mend that language
to have it go back to 5 days from a
department
decision sounds good okay and then the
the next don't blessing Ken um the uh
the next section has to do with the
composition of the workers compensation
appeal board in the last version of
House Bill 2 we reduced the overall size
of that board because the volume is just
not quite the same this this sort of
normalizes the language it really it
doesn't make any change to anything but
the the the law as it now now stands
says on thus date uh the commissioner
shall reduce the board from this I so it
was it was awkward to leave in there in
that state is changing the the language
to be more reflective of the current
circumstances we had another one that
had a problem because of the way that um
the
board somebody moved like out of state
but there their board position was like
for five years or until they resign and
the guy never resigned right but he was
not showing up either I don't know if
your language has has any kind of
problems like that maybe we should look
into that do you remember Melissa this
other board um no no you know you're
looking blank
so okay I I'll see if I can was it
land was it land was it that one I don't
know I thought it was something else in
too
yeah um all right well we'll think about
that or maybe it was a bill
right maybe it might have been a
bill I don't think anything in hb2 is
about that we had Public Employee labor
relation board speak about a fee that
was in hb2 but I to my no this is like
changing maybe it's just a bill I saw
but it had to do with um the members of
a board right and and for some
reason they had problems because like I
said somebody like retired and moved out
of state but never gave up their board
position and the way the the the thing
was written was the governor couldn't
reappoint this person until they quit
right and and so even though they were
gone you know what I mean so anyways I
I'll see if I can find it may have been
flood control because we couldn't ever
get a quorum and someone wasn't showing
up oh okay yeah I'll see if I can find
it I think it was a bill all right yeah
that'll be on me let's let me make a
redo just for the committee's sake
um we're going to get a list from the
speaker's office of like 15 commissions
to get rid of because they're not
meeting you know I mean it's one of
these things where I'm sure you're
you're on a bunch of commissions that uh
for sure yeah but probably you don't
have to be or don't want to or something
I don't know
or shouldn't be or shouldn't yeah right
um Governor's Point okay go ahead next
one sure uh and then the next section
that we're asking for is to make um make
it clear that the the records and
proceedings of the workers comp appeals
board that is administratively attached
to us to make it clear that those
records are all confidential as well um
the attorney general has a different
opinion than we do about the
overriding confidentiality Statute in
the workers comp law we just this is
just to make it clear that that board
that appell at board is also
confidential um and the next section is
just um uh removing uh gender specific
language relative to the commissioner
because someday it could be Danielle so
MH
right um and let's see hearing oh do you
want to talk about them the hearing
notices so so the next one is um looking
to make a change to the way that workers
compensation hearing notices issues to
parties uh when electronic issuance is
at issue currently the statute
authorizes electronic issuance which
would include via email which is
currently a a very you know postco an
incredibly popular method and modality
of communication only authorizes the
department to serve notice
electronically when both parties give
Express consent to receive
electronically um there are times when
the frequent times when the department
can't get parties to respond um we will
issue the notice both by regular mail
and then by email because we have at
least one email address on file from one
of the parties um when notices do come
back as undeliverable and oddly enough
they frequently do uh then um we have
difficulty issuing electronically even
if we have a uh email address on file if
we can't get the consent from the other
party or can't get them to respond in a
timely manner that causes delays it's
additional Staffing time to process both
the mail process the return mail and
then try to get good contact information
or get someone to respond for electric
is uh electronic issuance from both
parties so it proposes to allow the
department to um issue electronically to
one party when that party consents so
long as notice is made to both parties
um either via mail or by the phone calls
in some case yes I mean to try to get a
hold of that contact information okay
yeah okay rep representative Sweeny
thank you sorry so sure this is more I
guess probably a policy question for you
but when you're communicating with
workers about if they're emailing the
department on complaints do you advise
them to use a personal email versus a
work email
or is it that's a that's a great
question I I don't believe we give
guidance one way or the other um when
we're talking about somebody filing a
complaint with the Department we're
typically talking about an employee
who's filing what we would call a wage
and hour complaint they're um notifying
the department about a problem or
concern with their employer relative to
payment of wages or hours worked or
things of that nature and and it's
whatever email address they want to use
with us um I will say I believe most of
them are not utilizing their employee
addresses um on the workers compensation
side complaints don't typically um
complaints can come in when Injured
Workers are not represented by an
attorney they tend to use their
individual emails on occasion you will
see an uh a work email address from an
injured worker right thank you that was
just a sure curiosity that I had when
you were
talking anything
else um there's something that somebody
this triggered May somebody brought back
to me with that we had two years ago
called the second injury fund do you
remember this yeah sorry do you remember
that situation oh I remember vividly
okay so tell me we didn't do anything
right or something but we maybe should
have I don't know what do you think yes
uh what we had proposed to governor
sonunu was that we Sunset um the special
fund which is called the um second
injury fund it it is um it was an effort
to uh ensure that workers who were hired
uh like the friend that you described uh
who had previously been injured it's
it's um it's a tool to recoup some of
the cost if if a person were to have a
subsequent injury um the the problem
that we see is that in the modern era
with the Americans with Disabilities at
it it sort of Trumps that that uh
function um because you really should
not be as an employer you really should
not be asking questions about prior
injuries in in a hiring decision there's
a short window of time when you can do
that between hiring and and a start date
when you can find out that and then they
give would give that information to the
insurance carrier who who then can in
the event of a subsequent CL subsequent
claim can can make a claim against the
second injury fund and recuit some of
their cost all of the costs are paid
back to insurance
carriers uh or self-insured injury uh
self-insured
entities and all of the costs of those
payments are
build through that mechanism that I
mentioned earlier and it's literally it
can be as much as double the size of my
operating budget it has been as big as
in recent 22 $22
million um uh so we proposed to governor
sonunu in the last house bill too that
um that we Sunset that and stop taking
claims um uh during during the house
phase it it was removed through
Amendment from from house bill to so we
did not propose it again here
representative
lean yeah I think we had the former
Senate President bragon here that
testified against the legislation there
was a lot of push back I remember at the
time but you still think it's a good
idea well it's uh to my mind it is
revenue neutral to the industry it's
literally one carrier is taking money
from another carrier right but it it had
an effect on the state budget as I
remember right no no effect
oh no effect no because I thought we
spent or we received or something no for
our own employees well yes yes the there
there is that possibility yes that the
state the state had not traditionally
been very good at this function right it
was something like Das had to actively
pursue these kind of claims and we
weren't doing it so therefore we were
getting charged more than we were
receiving something like that right
because this is here yeah that's correct
yes yes so maybe if we got rid of it we
wouldn't have to pursue this this
bureaucratic thing right and therefore
we we save money yeah and you know my my
building it it involves some effort in
my building the Attorney General would
also tell you that because because they
have to defend the fund in the event of
denied claims and such they have they
have a fair amount of activity uh
associated with the second injury fund
that they don't they would prefer not to
do okay so so Melissa can you kind of re
resurrect this idea okay all right very
good anybody else no represent leash we
still on House Bill to I saw an item
that uh representative Sweeny would
probably support on page 60 there was a
fee it's only $50 for the elevator
certificate and I was just curious when
that was last increase cuz $50 seems
like a awful small amount of money to
have someone go out and check an
elevator especially if they bring in a
ton of of
[Laughter]
weight it's uh uh it has not been
increased at least as long as I've been
at the labor department and probably not
for many many years like what 15 years
or oh I I would think I would think it's
got to be at least at least but I but I
don't know you know I eight years here
so I can I I have a little elevator
story about the State House you know
there are two elevators in the state
house that appear identical but it turns
out they discovered they have completely
different mechanisms one has uh a cable
that pulls it up and down and the other
has a
hydraulic that moves it up and down
right and so just cuz you know one was
done in this era and one was done in
that therea it's it's very interesting
and if you don't do what you're told
they'll cut the cable when
[Laughter]
you okay anything else no all right well
thank you very much for coming
commission absolutely pleasure do we
want the
RSA for the second injury
50 the $50 elevator yeah well he's
getting us all kinds of fee related
information
okay oh well it's in the house bill to
right so when we go over the detail yeah
yeah because we're we're asking for uh a
process change but it could be that at
the same time we absolutely sure okay
very good thank you how many elevator
inspections are there per year uh 5,000
tough
well well I don't think they weight test
I don't think they weight test every
time it's not in every not it's for
acceptance right and that's only when we
there thank thank you all thank you
bye all right so tomorrow
um we have a very heavy day I believe
right so there's some agencies with with
much bigger budgets and things like that
so all right we'll see you at 10 right
yeah okay thank
you I don't know Melissa do you
know I think we have the AG as one of
right yeah go ahead yeah so we have um
we do have the Attorney General's office
coming in we have YDC coming in um so we
start at 10 with Department of Business
economic Affairs then Department of AD
they're complicated yeah Y and then
administrative Services which is very
complicated uh 115 we have Department of
Justice 25 Human Rights Commission and
then 245 we have the YDC settlement fund
yeah so the these are all big all
important so maybe read through your
yeah he actually won't be here but he
has some but I do have a letter that was
um emailed to a couple of you on here
but I have the official letter for the
out oh good question did you
the this house bu to stuff you talked